all right awesome so we're officially
live thank you for that david thank you
jordan peterson for coming back for this
i think this is fourth or fifth time of
us having you on
howard thanks
strange
but good
yeah so i started my tour
about 10 days ago
i saw joe rogan first
and that was really good and
seemed to
provoke a lot of outrage in the
predictable places
and um we need more of that though
yeah well we're going to get rich we're
going to get more so
so i don't think we're going to have to
wish for that that's just going to
happen and then i've done seven
tour lectures so far and
with an average audience size of about
2500 and
they're going great they're unbelievably
positive everybody almost everybody
dresses up which i think is really cool
really yeah well when i went on tour in
before i went out i thought i wanted to
do this like 100 percent right or at
least as close to that as i could manage
so i went out and bought
some expensive suits and i spent way
more money on this is one of them
actually
you look great thank you thank you way
more money than i ever thought i'd spend
on clothes and i really felt quite bad
about it you know i thought maybe it was
an extravagance but i thought no way man
i'm gonna see if i can nail this dead on
and i'm going to be speaking to you know
100 000 people i'm going to
look as sharp as i possibly can
and
one of the consequences of that has been
that
young men in particular come to the
lecture two are dressed up in suits
three-piece suits they're when the
couples come and they're dressed up like
they're coming to a wedding or
so that's really something and why do
you think that is why is it because you
said that sick act and like kids okay
you know our whole culture pushes the
idea that teenage
life or even childhood for that matter
but teenage life is some sort of
pinnacle and then everybody dresses down
so they look especially men they look
like overgrown 10 year olds and there's
something extremely demeaning about that
and so to provide people with
opportunity to
dress up in a in a classic manner and to
look like adults to present themselves
in that manner
there's something very attractive about
that because we haven't done that in our
culture that's been
i would say
downplayed in importance or
or or
for
certainly since the 1960s who's to blame
for that because you recall anytime you
would fly an airplane if you see old
school pictures people are dressed in
three piece suits to go on an airplane
this is in the 60s i assume and then now
you see someone like mark zuckerberg
wear a t-shirt to give a speech in front
of a ted talk or something like that
some of it's just fashion you know i
mean fashion moves around and then
and it's it usually drifts from the top
down and so when formality becomes the
norm but that drifts down to say to the
working class then the upper class
thinks well we can't do that because
that would you know associate us with
the unfashionable people and then they
dress down and so then that drifts down
the hierarchy and so there's some of
that some of it's just fashion but a lot
of it too is this
idea that
this sort of
reflexive rebellious attitude that
anything that violates traditional norms
or even anything that's associated with
patriarchal oppression and adulthood is
to be
eliminated in favor of what's
hypothetically a more free individuality
but it's not because everybody looks the
same i was in washington
four or five years ago maybe longer than
that it's probably longer than that when
i first went in the summer and one of
the things that really struck me all
these people wandering around these
great monuments is all the men looked
like overgrown 10 year olds they looked
exactly like their kids except they were
bigger they looked like they'd been
inflated with a bicycle pump and i
thought this is weird that
that adults are dressing like children
and not good and so some of it's fashion
but some of it's also that is it
exclusive in america how about in canada
what have you seen all over the world
with this no i don't think it's
exclusive to america i think it it was
more noticeable to me in washington and
i think that's when it really hit me
because washington has in some sense a
place of pilgrimage and
people from every class go there and
that's that's a good thing and and they
should from every economic class and so
it was like a cross it was a real
cross-section of the total population
and that was one of the things that
struck me quite quite bluntly and so
anyways it's very nice to see all these
people dressed up and when you hear the
argument being made that's the following
argument the argument is look
uh
you you you only have so much energy to
make so many decisions throughout your
day do you want to be in front of the
closet in the morning picking and
choosing what suit i'm going to wear to
tie with what shirt and what tie you
know what i'd much rather not
consume my energy thinking about what
outfit to put together it's a lot easier
to just have a white shirt
jeans
regular tennis shoes and go to work and
let me make the bigger decisions while
i'm running the company i've never felt
bad not wearing a suit every time i've
had a suit on i felt better than just
walking with a t-shirt on even though
the t-shirt is a lot
easier to do you know it's a lot easier
even when you were in the military it
felt good
having your greens on you know having
your bdu on there was something
uh very attractive about having a suit
on not not for the audience just even
for yourself you felt good having a
uniform on i don't know yeah well my i
talked to my father about this years ago
um because he always wore a suit when he
was a teacher he's still alive he's a
teacher and
he always wore a suit and i asked him
why one day and he said because it was
his way of showing respect for the
students
and
i mean i'm not saying that everyone who
doesn't dress in the suit is being
disrespectful but there's something
about
outfitting yourself for the task at hand
and there's also something about
attempting to put some effort into
presenting your putting your best foot
forward and i don't really buy that it
takes more time in the morning argument
it takes a bit more time but once you
like
before i went on this tour i went
through all my clothing and i tossed out
everything that didn't fit and which
included a number of suits that were old
and i had to organize them and that took
about a day to get my closet in order
and
but then it
from then on it only i is actually a
pleasure in some sense because you do it
yourself
do i do meaning like you go through your
closet you do it yourself like pat has a
very unique way of like you don't pack
anymore pat do you like you have someone
no kind of help you out with that
packing is not my strength in my life i
have a lot that's one of my weaknesses
no i still did that for the tour because
i had to figure out what i was going to
wear and but i've had people
help me make clothing decisions let's
say now it's often people who would like
to make suits for me so so i have that
as an advantage and but uh
i did that pretty much
on my own and
anyway so the well we were talking about
the tour it's going extremely well and
so people come and they're dressed up
and they look good not everybody dresses
up but everybody looks pretty good
and uh i like that i like when you go
into a room and people are dressed up by
the way just for the audience just so
you know what topics we'd like to cover
with you today number one we'd like to
cover
what a fantastic job your your leader is
doing trudeau and i know you're a big
fan of his we'll cover him a little bit
with the truckers on what they got going
on up there
in canada uh two we'll talk about what
happened with whoopi goldberg i'm
curious to know what your thoughts on
what should happen to with the comments
she made
about the holocaust
some of the stuff that's going on right
now with john hopkins today report came
out talking about how great of an idea
was the shutdown and no one's talking
about it they said it was point two
percent effective love to get your
thoughts on that some uh uh issues with
a uh the governor who came out with what
they're doing was trends uh genderism
governor noam on the fairness bill i'd
be curious to know what you have to say
about that and a few other topics that
we got going on that's more on the
personal side when does divorce make
sense that's a question adam's really
curious about and then some other
questions so
today do you still live in canada today
are you still full-time living in canada
right now uh in so far as i live
anywhere full-time it's in canada i have
a house in toronto and we bought a new
place about three hours north of toronto
on a lake which uh we spent a lot of
time in
six months very close to right now it's
that area yeah it's awesome up there
yeah it is it's beautiful up there and
so that's been real nice um my daughter
moved to nashville partly to escape from
the covid restrictions and for other
reasons as well because nashville has a
really burgeoning creative culture and
it's a very cool place great city yeah
it's a great city and real estate still
is relatively inexpensive certainly by
toronto standards
um so yes why are you still in canada
why are you still living in canada
well i'm living in toronto because my
son and his wife and their their their
son
live on the same street that we lived on
we we
they purchased a house four years ago i
think it was four years ago and
that was before
i assumed that i would be in toronto for
the rest of my life because i assumed i
would work at the university of toronto
and continue doing what i was doing
until i was like 90 because i really
liked doing it and there was just no
reason to assume and i had a clinical
practice which i also really liked and
so that was pretty good life
and i assumed we were there permanently
and my son liked toronto and so
we
picked up a house and
and they lived there and so but that's
really the reason i'm still in toronto
and how that'll play out over time i
don't really know
so because i'm sure you're seeing
everybody that's moving you know you got
joe
who went from uh california to austin
you saw shapiro whose company is in
nashville but he's living here in boca
right you're seeing reuben
who i think just moved in uh to i want
to say miami right you got elon musk
musk goes to austin you got your
daughter who went to nashville right you
got all these people that are looking at
you know
nashville florida texas it seems like
those three states tend to make people
the most comfortable and they're all red
state
what needs to happen for jordan peterson
to say
i'm kind of leaving canada to go to a
different state would anything happen
that would cause you to leave that place
well i don't think as long as my son's
there i don't think so because that's a
big advantage to being there but we're
doing so much traveling my wife and i
that in some sense we don't live
anywhere you know i mean we were we were
three weeks two weeks in the uk and then
a week in washington and now we've been
on the road we're going to be on the
road pretty much non-stop till march of
2023 because this the tour ends in the
states in
in at the end of april we'll hit 40
cities
and then canada assuming
that's possible but it looks like it
probably will be and then the uk and
europe we're going to be back in canada
for two months in the summer
and then down to new zealand and
australia and southeast asia and then
i'm going to cambridge i believe in
january
to do a seminar on exodus which is what
i wanted to do at cambridge multiple
years ago before they canceled me and
but that's all been sorted out and so it
looks like there's a very high
probability that that will occur
and then that's really as far out as
we've looked so that'd be march of 2023
and god only knows what shape the
world's going to be in at that point
there's hardly any sense in planning out
past that because everything is in such
flux there's no predicting the future i
ask the question for the following
reasons so
you know there are certain people
who do a lot of work behind closed doors
but nobody knows them there's a lot of
smart people that are
very intellectual great teachers
you know great students loyalty a ton of
strong philosophies who maybe would make
a great leader but we don't know them
right
and very few it's it's very very few 0.1
all of a sudden boom overnight the world
knows who they are
and they're enamored by this person
you're one of them it's kind of what
happened to you
overnight jordan who's jordan peterson
well the people who are in toronto would
know who jordan peterson is
professor teacher clinical i think you
said you had 20 patients or 20 families
that you were working on i think that
was the number so it's not like it's in
the tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands overnight
the world's addicted to jordan peterson
who is this guy and then you have your
moment with the lady that's pushing you
feminist and then that goes off and
wow this man's deep then you write the
book
sells millions on top of millions of
copies so then money is being generated
money's coming in then everybody else
comes in hey speaking this speaking that
and that that adds up that starts
getting a lot of money and then
you had your moment where i remember
when i interviewed you on stage
that that event was a very special event
because it was you and then i had also
george bush i interviewed at that event
as well as uh the late kobe bryant if
you remember that event that was one
event six thousand people and you got
emotional on stage when we talked about
your wife and your daughter
and i walked off the stage and i said i
think he's dealing with something i
don't know what it is talking to my wife
i said uh i think this guy is dealing
with something and that was your last
live event that you did and you kind of
went hiatus and you know the whole thing
that you were dealing with with the
medication and all that stuff but
then i kind of sit and i think about
you know a jordan peterson's okay so he
makes a comeback
when you go to a dark place and you come
back
i would assume you may sit there and say
you know stuff that i thought i valued
it's not really that valuable i value
this though and maybe use the value that
82 percent now it's 90 percent you know
and stuff they used to value at 48
percent they give energy to because
other people care you're down to 22
percent i really don't give a about
this i don't know why i'm even putting
so much time into it right
and then you come out and when you come
out
you're kind of like looking around
saying
god why did i go through this what was
this all about this was kind of strange
should i see someone like you yesterday
i posted something saying look this
whole thing with spotify and rogan i'm
sure we'll get into we'll talk about it
because i'd be curious know what you
have to say about that i really want to
know your thoughts
i said you know
in in in a very strange way i would love
spotify to drop rogan and we're talking
i said why why would you want spotify to
drop rogan i said because the first
phone call rogen would get us from elon
musk
and elon musk would say hey don't worry
about it let's go compete i'm going to
start something you be the face let's
get a bunch of podcasters come with us
and let's go do something
so i put this video out there and i got
commentary people that are posting stuff
one guy said that's just not rogan
rogan's not trying to be a hero he's not
trying to be a legend he's not trying to
be that i said well if you read the
journey of a hero as he fights it
until eventually it's kind of like
listen man
i know you don't want to do this but
it's kind of like
you could really address a lot of things
and you're the right guy for but i don't
want to do it we see this in movies all
the time it's the constant fight fight
fight fight fight
i asked a question with you in canada
because
you know who gets more eyeballs in
canada than you i don't know
and is canada in a pretty strange place
right now with the way true those handle
things where he used to talk about
freedom and we can't ever make people do
anything to their bodies that they don't
want to do it all okay this guy makes
sense boom no if we have to choose
between delivering food and delivering
this we're gonna choose this because
you're like this guy sounds like a
dictator okay is there any aspiration
we're in a moment like this
with all of these weird things taking
place worldwide where maybe you've sat
down behind closed doors with your
family with somebody and have said you
know
dad
jordan why don't you go in there and see
if you can be
the leader of a great country like
canada and do something about it
has that conversation ever taken place
at this phase of your life yes
and
well
i've thought about a political career at
different points throughout my whole
life starting literally starting when i
was 14. in fact that's what i thought i
would do when i was 14. i worked for a
political party in canada it was a
socialist party
as it turns out and uh
i had that option open to me when i was
extremely when i was very young but i
figured out when i was about 16 that i
didn't really know anything
and so i had ideas and i was capable of
functioning in the realm of ideas and
putting them forth even then i would say
in a somewhat compelling manner but i i
figured out partly because i'd worked
with a lot of small business people
and
also on the board of governors of this
little college i went to these are all
people who'd built businesses from the
bottom up they're all immigrants because
everybody in northern alberta was an
immigrant and they didn't share my
left wing presuppositions but they were
very admirable people and part of what
made them admirable to me
wasn't their facility with ideological
conceptions so it wasn't an intellectual
attraction it was a practical attraction
like i'd worked in restaurants in this
little town i grew up in fairview and uh
i liked working with the guys that that
that built the restaurant and
i talked to them one day about uh
the socialist party in canada and
alberta at that time had a pretty good
small business platform probably better
than the conservatives had in terms of
what it would do for small businesses
and i asked them one day why aren't you
in favor of this small business platform
because they wouldn't vote for the ndp
the socialist party to save their lives
they said well
we don't want to be small business
people
we want to be big business people and so
i learned then
well the guy i worked with his name was
scotty kyle and scotty was a rough guy
he was about 35 i was about 15 at that
time and scotty had been an alcoholic
and he had like all his teeth knocked
out in fights and like he was a rough
guy but he was super funny and he was
really smart and he said to me one day
people don't vote their reality they
vote their dreams
i thought hey man that's a good phrase
you know that stuck in my mind for the
rest of my life and so
so in any case
when i went to college i went
i was going to i went to to take
political science and literature and i
wanted to go into law school i wrote the
lsat and i was set to go to law school i
want to take corporate law and the
reason that i wanted to do that was to
understand my enemy that was the idea
and who was your enemy well i was doing
this when i was social
yeah yeah the big corporations
essentially big corporations you know
but i i realized
about a year into my college education
for a variety of reasons that partly
reading george orwell but that wasn't
all of it that um
i also didn't like i i went to a lot of
the uh ndp party and its new democratic
party it's not the ndp party new
democratic party conventions
provincially and nationally and i'm i
had access to the leadership for a
variety of reasons
a lot of the leaders were
reasonably admirable people or maybe
even completely admirable people who had
worked with labor unions and like they
were really they were advocates for the
working class in a real sense
uh
but the party level activists i never
liked them from the beginning i thought
i don't trust you guys you just seem to
be driven by resentment
not not genuine care for the working
class and
so that that didn't sit well with me any
case i started to get interested in
psychological motivations for political
behavior especially as i went through my
political science degree because there
was increasing emphasis as we moved away
from the classics which is what i
studied in the first couple of years to
more
modern political thinking let's say it
was all
quasi-marxist in that the political
scientists believed intrinsically that
people were only motivated by economic
concerns
and i just never believed that i thought
that's
which economic concerns and why well
those questions weren't asked by
political scientists they took economic
determinism as a starting point and that
never sat well with me i thought there
was a mystery there because
it wasn't obvious to me what motivated
people and we're not ruled by our
bellies as far as i'm concerned so the
idea of pure economic determinism was a
non-starter and that's really when i
started to get interested in psychology
and i've made a choice all the way
through my life the choice has always
been
say political sociological versus
psychological
or perhaps spiritual and i've always
chosen the psycho psychological work at
the level of the individual and i don't
think i'm going to stop doing that i
mean
i have
had discussions serious discussions with
people about a political career and
first of all in my current situation it
isn't obvious to me at all that that
wouldn't be less effective than what i'm
already doing
you know so that wouldn't be less
effective yeah yeah it'd be less
effective yes it would be less effective
for me what do you mean by that well i
mean i know what you mean by that but
what do you mean by that you mean to
tell me you would you're you're having
the same amount of impact now as you
would as the pm no i think more yeah
right now you're having more impact yeah
yeah look those are hard jobs and it's
very and you get boxed in very quickly
and they're also brutal jobs and it
isn't obvious to me that i have the
stomach for it i don't really like
fights
in fact i don't like them at all part of
the reason that i
said what i said back in 2016 when i
first stood up and voiced opposition to
what the universities were doing and
also what my government was doing was
because i could see where that was going
i could see that it was going to
generate conflict of all sorts i knew
for example that all this pronoun
foolishness was going to confuse
thousands particularly of young women
because there's a whole there's an
a very large clinical history of that
sort of thing happening for 350 years
so that's detailed in a book called the
history of the unconscious which is a
great book by a man named
henry ellenberger who wrote the best
book on the history of psychoanalytic
thinking and so i knew that
in any case part of the reason i spoke
up and this was a hallmark of my
clinical practice and also of the manner
in which my family was organized is like
we're gonna have that fight right now
and we're gonna make peace because i
don't wanna have this fight
every day for the rest of my life
and so it's gonna be a pain to fight
through it because it's always a pain to
fight through a conflict but if you can
fight through it
you can make peace and then you don't
have the conflict and i really don't
like conflict
so
i don't like it deferred because i know
what happens if conflict is deferred you
get weaker because you backed off and
the conflict gets more intense because
its tentacles grow in a sense it's like
not paying your not paying a utility
bill it's like
for the first month it's not that big a
problem but
i don't know i'm i'm trying to think to
say that you think you're making a
bigger impact right now than being a pm
i don't have a hard time with that let
me let me unpack my question and
challenge me on this sure so uh so so
okay so let's just say
uh
who is jimmy fallon he is the
you know hey i'd like to be like a jimmy
johnny carson hypothetically like that's
the
fallon carson right who is i don't know
uh
tucker carlson maybe he's trying to be a
o'reilly or maybe whoever it is that the
lineage that you're going through right
okay who's this latest person trying to
have a show she's trying to be the next
oprah winfrey right
who would you say what jordan peterson
is doing in history
who would you have been in the 16 or
whatever the you know the century would
go to who was jordan peterson like if
you were to give a
a 100 years from now what are people
going to say who jordan peterson was
they're not going to say
oh he was a professor
oh he was a clinical psychologist oh he
was an author i don't think they're
going to say that what do you think
people are going to
correlate you to 100 years from now i i
really have no idea so let's just say is
it like a philosopher plato would you
say you're more of a philosopher would
you say you're more like an aristotle do
you see yourself more as that do you see
yourself as
look i'm just somebody that's sharing my
thoughts and my life experiences
i think i'm a clinical psychologist okay
so that's kind of how you see yourself
yeah yeah there's a great there's a
lineage of great clinical psychologists
i'm not saying that i'm in that lineage
but i would say that people who are the
most similar to me are people like well
carl rogers might be an example okay i
mean he didn't have the same social
media platform but of course no one did
but that's how i see myself
intellectually really really as a
psychologist as a clinical psychologist
and i think that the work i'm doing
on my lecture tour is a hybrid of being
a professor and being a clinical
psychologist but is it fair to say
that's who you were but you've evolved
into something way bigger than just
being a clinical psychologist i think
that's what pat's yeah no you're kind of
getting out he's comparing you to an
aristotle of some capacity yeah well i
don't know because
my focus is still on the individual even
when i'm lecturing in front of
large audiences and i don't exactly
lecture i explore ideas in front of
audiences which is what rogan does and i
do that even when i'm when it's a
monologue
you know and you think well how can you
be exploring ideas with the audience
when it's a monologue and answer is
well
you're attending to the audience you're
watching them to see if they understand
and if they're nodding and what they're
responding to like there's a dynamism
about it and but it's all focused on the
individual
and there's been some unbelievably
influential clinical psychologists or
psychiatrists i mean freud was
unbelievably influential and so was carl
jung and there's a half dozen sure so so
i see that i'm in that tradition now the
fact that
this information now can be disseminated
in audio form and video form makes the
playing field radically different and so
i was also a very early adopter of those
technologies so when i blew up let's say
it happened overnight it's not not
exactly like because most of these
things don't happen exactly it takes 20
years to overblow well yeah yeah
the first doublings are invisible right
yeah but that live outside of the
university yeah well that was that's
that's listen everybody's like who is
this guy yeah he's right he makes sense
so there was a concept of well sure
there was a tipping point there that was
when when there was a free speech rally
outside my
office at the university of toronto it
wasn't organized by me but i was invited
to speak as was anyone who wanted to
speak by the way at that event and then
a bunch of radical types tried to shut
it down with white noise and they were
very annoying and
some of them were clearly psychopathic
some of the people i watched them
because i have pretty good eye for that
and some of the men that came out they
were bad bad actors in any case i got
shanghaied on the way back into my
office
by these these
hypothetically trans activists mostly
young people what do you mean shanghai
well they just surrounded me you know
that's that's all i mean ganged up on
well
kind of they were they were
disrespectful which i wasn't very
thrilled about because i think that
it's not a good
if students are being disrespectful to
to to professors
something's wrong that's not
that's not what happens at a university
i i had
no tolerance for that in my classes if
you were out of line you are more than
welcome to leave now and that didn't
mean you couldn't challenge me
intellectually that was absolutely fine
if you had a smart question you were
paying attention
i didn't care what your opinion was but
you know maybe when you're a junior high
teacher or an elementary school teacher
you have to put up with misbehavior as a
professor i put up with there's like
zero misbehavior no misbehavior we're
adults we're not doing that at all did
you set the tone for that day one in the
first class like this is how i roll yeah
i never had trouble with students in my
classes well a
handful of students would pretty much
always leave
the first lecture i gave particularly my
personality class because a lot of them
didn't who i was in my smaller classes
people already knew who i was so that
never happened but in my personality
class there'd always be six or seven
people in the first lecture would make a
show of leaving and it was because of
the tone i set which was
don't muck about in this class
at all you're here to listen or not you
can leave if you don't want to listen
but this is a serious endeavor any case
these students surrounded me
and they filmed it and then they put it
online and the object was to discredit
me but that didn't work
and but the reason it didn't work in
part and this is
why this wasn't only overnight was i
already had a hundred hours of lectures
on youtube and i basically recorded
everything i ever said to students in
any professional capacity and what i
said in my classes was exactly the same
as what i said when i wasn't in my
classes so there was no there's no show
there
and so people came
to look to see what was going on they
came to my youtube channel and it had
like 35 000 fifty thousand subscribers
at that point which wasn't none
especially that early on in youtube
development
and they found out that what i was
saying was not only completely unlike
what i was accused of saying but it was
exactly the opposite partly because you
know i was accused of being this radical
right-wing figure and i'd lectured about
the evils of national socialism at
harvard and at the university of toronto
for like 20 years
so the idea that i was somehow radically
right wing was not only a lie
there's lies where you bend the truth
right that's one kind of lie i think
what the i think what those lectures did
is a way for people to not be able to
taint your name by saying i actually
like what this guy has to say
35 000 subscribers is not a lot of
subscribers no but this is where i'm
going with this so you're saying you see
yourself as a clinical psychologist
right okay uh great
you know
sometimes the challenge i have is to
follow like i you know i sit down why is
he still in canada maybe there's bigger
aspirations to stay in canada because he
loves his country and he'd like to see
canada become the country that he chose
to live when he was a kid growing up and
he's got memories mom dad family all
this stuff so maybe to him because some
people don't want to leave a country
because they want to make a political
contribution to that country some people
are like listen what country is going to
give me the best tax benefits and
freedom i'm going to go there i'm
totally cool i'm going to go to
singapore i'll do my bitcoins i'll go to
puerto rico pay four percent on taxes
this is what i'm going to be doing right
you seem like a very deep guy here's
where i go with this
in my life
i've experienced a lot of weird things
iran war divorce parents politics
military you know all this weird things
out of business you've seen coming up
and hey we're so supportive of you we
want to see when patrick and then i
start kind of getting big and all of a
sudden we're getting babies like oh we
don't like you anymore what happened you
like me when i was small you don't like
me when i'm big i'm the same person
what's the problem here right
here's what i've noticed
those who are driven by
force
are more ambitious
on imposing
and having control
than those who are driven by choice let
me unpack this meaning
you know
sometimes people that are driven by
force are more inspired to get involved
in politics and create laws than those
who are driven by choice choice is kind
of like listen let me leave me alone let
me alone let me go live my life right
but i think sometimes it's kind of like
you know you made this one example you
know
who made this example somebody was on
yesterday saying look
you know the way i look at foreign
relations mike ritlin is if i go to a
bar
and if a fight's breaking into a bar and
i go in there no matter what if i go in
there and fight i'm going to piss off
one side whether if i defend a girl or
the guy someone's going to be upset with
me because i chose to fight right it
says america is kind of like that you're
getting into a lot of these fights and
you're getting involved in these there's
a fight going on your country right now
yours
and
people are still listening to this guy
he's still got influence
and you got you know you know these
truckers that are coming out they're
saying listen you can't make us do this
there's 5 500 mile america this you want
us to get vaccinated you want us we
don't want to do it we want this freedom
don't you think
you know
this may be a good time for you to throw
your name in the you know and say hey
you know what i'm gonna go and here's
why because i think 100 years from when
we sit here and talk about who was the
main philosopher when lincoln was
president
only people in that world are gonna know
who that person is but everyone's gonna
know who lincoln is and what lincoln did
and the impact he made right
do i think his life was a you know a
peaceful life if you've read about
lincoln and his marriage and that one
friend he would travel with and when you
go to smithsonian then they show the
evolution of how much he aged it's a
pretty it's a lot of burden of what this
guy went through right but he was chosen
and he was the right guy for it
you don't at all feel like
you know
no it's again i think
i can detail out some of the reasons
sure i think i'm more effective doing
what i'm doing well i'm working with a
lot of political people in the united
states both on the republican and the
democrat side all the time and i
couldn't do that if i was
involved
formally and technically in politics in
canada i'm working with a bunch of
people in the uk as well
and so and i'm working with people in
canada it's just more effective for me
to do what i'm doing i don't know about
that
i don't know well i can give you an
example with the truckers you know so
and
a couple of examples so
a week and a half ago
the former premier of newfoundland so
equivalent of the governor of the state
he was the premier in in the 1980s
and uh he was one of the drafters of the
canadian charter of rights so he
actually wrote it with a bunch of other
people but he was one of them and he's a
mainstream solidly admired politician
across the spectrum regarded as a decent
guy
and he mounted a constitutional
challenge to the vaccine mandates
announced it a week ago
stating that see they put an emergency
provision in the charter saying that
under certain emergency conditions true
emergencies that charter rights could be
suspended in the case of a national
emergency but he's not convinced in the
least that
the covid epidemic even at its height
constituted such an emergency he said
that was not the intent of the drafters
and certainly doesn't constitute that
emergency now
and
so he talked me through this and i
thought well isn't this interesting we
have a person who actually drafted the
chart of rights saying that the and a
former premier of a major province
saying that the government is acting in
an essentially unconstitutional manner i
don't think that's ever happened in the
history of a western democracy and i
said well
okay that's something
he's 82 now sharp as attack
why do you want to announce this on my
podcast
because
that's
preposterous and he said well our team
has talked it over and we don't think
there's one news source in canada that
will handle this credibly
i thought that's not good so we released
that a week and a half ago which was
timed very nicely as it turned out with
the truckers protest
because people are saying well are the
truckers breaking the law
and the question is
well just exactly who's breaking law
here
and that's by no means obvious
and so
that was extremely helpful and then
about
a few days after that i
released another video
calling on the conservative types in
canada to seize the moment
given this popular uprising and the fact
that countries all over the world are
dropping the covid
mandates
to seize the moment and drop the
mandates at a provincial level it's
enough is enough and
somebody's got to be the first actor and
so that got million and a half views in
no time flat and
so i'm able to play a useful role
as a well on the media front weirdly
enough but also as a
someone who's standing apart from the
from the details of the political fray i
mean i get that but you know it's like
saying
if reagan would have stayed being the b
actor or at ge going getting paid a
million dollars a year to go around the
world and talking about his political
philosophies and how great he is or
president of sag would he have been able
to tell gorbachev to take that wall down
i don't think so would he have
influenced a country like russia to
become a little bit more free where
people are staying they're not leaving
they're a little bit more comfortable
staying there because now there's a
capitalistic opportunity it's no longer
communism karl marx and angle and those
guys don't have the influence that they
had before because stalin and lenin and
what travesty they did to people does
that credit go to gorbachev does it go
to who it goes to reagan right so if you
think about churchill and chamberlain it
was to soldier nitsan too i i told again
he was a writer obviously a writer and
so
it's look i mean it's not like you know
what i'm saying there isn't it's not
like
the political domain doesn't have its
purpose and its function
and but
there's a lot i would have to stop doing
if i did that and it isn't obvious to me
that that's the right thing for me to do
partly again because
i
started doing what i'm doing back in say
probably 1985
because i realized that
one of the pathways to totalitarian
catastrophe was
deceit at the individual level which is
something that soldier nitsan made very
much of orwell as well huxley as well
these great thinkers
concluded
in the aftermath of these totalitarian
catastrophes that there was an integral
link between
pathology at the individual level which
was fundamentally the willingness to use
deceit in an instrumental manner i'll
lie to you to get what i want and
authoritarian catastrophe and that it
was a direct causal link and actually by
that argument i think that's literally
true and so partly what i'm doing i hope
is
helping people walk through
thinking about why telling the truth is
a good idea
not not only for them
not not as a top down shake your finger
moral injunction don't lie you shouldn't
lie
but in an in a detailed manner to
explain the relationship between the
instrumental use of deceit and the
collapse of civilizations and that
connection is way closer than people
think you know so
one person is influenced as a thousand
people for sure in their lifetime and
sometimes a lot more than that and
a thousand you know the next rung out
from that a thousand times a thousand is
a million and the next rung out from
that is a billion and so you're always
at the center of a concentric circle
that two rungs out contains a billion
people
well it turns out that what you do
matters and
basically what i'm doing as i hope
is touring and talking to people face to
face in these lectures for example and
making the case that
it's a terrifying case everyone says
well we want meaning in our life it's
do you now
do you now because you might ask
yourself what's the more threatening
possibility
that nothing you do matters which means
you can pretty much do whatever you want
that's the upside of that nihilistic
claim no responsibility
right and why why not pursue narrow
focused hedonism since nothing matters
anyways so that's the shadow of nihilism
or everything you do matters
and it's a lot more
terrifying to contemplate that is that
you will be held accountable for
everything you do and i believe that
firmly partly as a consequence of my
clinical experience i never saw
any one of my clinical clients
ever get away with anything
even once
and you think well people get away with
things all the time it's like no they
don't they might
gain
a narrow advantage
in one dimension in the short term
but
you know let's say that you you're you
use deceit in your business practices
first of all that doesn't work very well
because people will figure you out so as
a long-term
as a long-term strategy it's terrible it
just doesn't work no one is going to
play with you if you're a cheat but
let's say
that
someone asked me someone asked me the
other day well what about these
dictators that that uh you know ruled
their whole life and and they were at
the top of the hierarchy let's say and
they had all the power stalin's a
perfectly good example
it's like didn't he win
well
everyone stellan ever talked to lied to
him because they were absolutely bloody
terrified of him his country was a
nightmare
it was a hell or as close as we've been
able to produce with the possible
exception of the nazis and the maoists
but it was up there in terms of hell and
did he rule
yes but he ruled hell and if you think
that's a victory well go ahead and try
it see how much of a victory it is you
know milton satan said i'd rather rule
in hell than serve in heaven
it's like fair enough go ahead use
deceit use instrumentality rule in hell
you'll be the ruler see how much good it
does you see where that takes you it
takes you somewhere terrible and so
i'm much more interested in talking
those things through with people and i
do do political work but
but
i it's not the right thing for me i got
the last question for you on this and
then we can move on to the next topic so
uh uh churchill you know his writing
what he did kind of started like you at
a very young age he's not he's a guy
that if you follow his writing the guy
has done a lot of stuff right and then
eventually last minute hey we can't
figure this guy out from germany we need
your help chamberlain stepped away hey
goes and recruits the guy that he hates
the most and we know how uh history ends
up we speak in english today big part of
it because of churchill but
this is the last question you know uh
how you said at this phase of my life
this is what i'm doing do you think um
do you think the right thing to do is
what
what's always what we want to do or
sometimes we have to do things that
maybe
uh uh
uh the world or family or somebody else
is relying on us to make a decision
that's more impactful than to the world
than what would be more fruitful to us
i think that happens a lot you know i
have a
i don't know a fantasy i suppose and i
don't know how well thought through it
is
but one of the things i've been thinking
about doing is i'm i'm writing another
book at the moment which i plan to
publish in the next year and a half or
something like that
it's called we who wrestle with god and
um
and perhaps there'll be a tour
associated with that and i want to do a
public lecture series on exodus but i've
been
pursuing more artistic endeavors
recently again uh in detail i did some
of that in
when i first went to graduate school i
made a variety of paintings and and so
forth that i really liked doing that and
i really liked doing this i've been
working on a musical project with a
friend of mine and with my family which
is really it's really fun i really like
it a lot and i wrote a screenplay that's
a musical which i really enjoyed doing i
have seemed to have somewhat of a gift
for writing verse weirdly enough
um especially amusing verse i i think
it's amusing and some other people have
thought so and it's really playful and
fun and i think i could do that
i could do a lot of that and it would be
in many ways
less
demanding than what i'm doing now
and i've talked to my family about that
but they seem to think that you know
when my wife and i planned this tour
i was unbelievably ill still and it just
seemed like a pipe dream that this was
ever going to occur but if we were going
to try it we had to do it months in
advance and so
but you know i outlined the tour for her
with my agents and she said i asked her
when we got off the phone i said do you
want to do this and she said yes and i
was quite surprised that actually i mean
tammy had been unbelievably ill for
months and months and months like at
death's doorstep every day for like
eight months it was awful
and yet she was on board and
you know it's it's got this great
adventurous element to it and
it seems
to your point that
the time is right for it whatever it is
and so away we go and that's what we're
doing and
it would be
possible in principle for me to
be in my cabin up north and
record music and
engage in artistic activities and
be with her and my family in a more
private way
now i don't know if i'm suited for that
you know
so that's why i'm saying well maybe it's
a pipe dream
because
i really like being as busy as i can
possibly be all the time you know and
i've kind of trained myself for that i
started training myself for that
really when i went to graduate school
because i wanted to find out how much i
could do and i like running at top speed
all the time and so maybe i wouldn't be
suited for that you know and
although
the days we've spent in the weeks we
spent engaged in it
i have an art book coming out a strange
art project is going to cause all sorts
of trouble
coming out probably in september or
october and a bunch of music that will
accompany that
which is also going to cause a lot of
trouble i believe um
i really enjoyed doing it it's it's
really engrossing and fun and playful
and
and i liked working on this screenplay
we've got a bunch of music being
recorded for it and that's called the
water of life the screenplay it's a
great old fairy tale
so but to your point sorry
you have a responsibility beyond
the narrow confines let's say of a
particular interest even if it's an
artistic interest in short interest sure
and you play the role that
is set in front of you that constitutes
the best path forward and there's
obviously a market for what i'm
discussing
a market let's say an interested
audience and so and i love doing that
too that's the other thing i love doing
it pat yeah can i ask you a question
because i think the line of questioning
that you're asking dr peterson is
overall
you're talking about being the reluctant
hero
that was the sort of the initial analogy
that you gave you gave with joe rogan
where like the guy said you know that's
not what joe is joe is not trying to be
a hero and you're like sometimes
you know it's not who you want to be
it's who people need you to be i mean
it's like the joe isn't trying to be
here no he's just being here no no okay
yeah but but you know it's almost like
neo from the matrix he's like it's like
we need you you're the chosen one what
are you talking about so pat
essentially what he's asking it was like
lincoln
you know churchill uh trump even these
are people whether they were reluctant
heroes or not these are people that had
chan have changed the world and you're
more saying like look
sigmund freud
gandhi
uh you know more the philosophical line
but ultimately what i think pat is
getting at is like who changes the world
more
dignitaries presidents prime ministers
or thinkers thinkers and you say it's
thinkers so that's all for sure it's
things okay so that is ultimately and
that's even why
yeah yeah so that's ultimately what your
line of questions are all i'm saying is
listen all i'm saying is the following
i'm sitting there looking at a lot of
guys that should there should throw
their name into
and go out there and compete and they're
not yeah and that's a problem yeah okay
well look a lot of the people i know
who would make
excuse me who would make
extraordinarily competent political
leaders so these are people who've
built
exceptionally complicated enterprises
from the bottom up in an extremely
creative and diligent way and who
mastered that
they won't throw their hat in the
political ring partly because
they have other things they're doing
that are they regard as more significant
and often they are and this is a big
problem because what it means is that
perhaps is that the pool of qualified
political candidates is much narrower
than it might otherwise be
so and that's something you're obviously
wrestling with ethically you know when
are you compa when you called upon to
throw your hat in the ring in some sense
despite your own personal interests
i don't have any
contempt for
the political arena you know i think
it's a big mistake for people people go
from naive to cynical
and then they think cynicism is wisdom
and it is compared to naivety
but it's not compared to what comes
after cynicism which is something like
courageous trust and that's the right
attitude towards that to have towards
the political sphere and often people
don't want to take the risk of
courageous trust and so they justify
that avoidance with their cynicism i'm
not like that i know the political realm
is valuable and necessary
and and i don't have contempt for it and
i don't think anyone should
it's it's a mistake because it's your
system man and you're a sovereign you're
a sovereign individual it's your system
if it's corrupt that's on you i can have
in a
definite sense and people say well there
isn't anything i can do is one person
it's like joe rogan's one person
and he didn't he his success is really
remarkable
first of all you can't just
push it aside as
chance because rogan was a good fighter
and that's hard
and then he was a good comedian and
that's really hard
maybe no harder than being a fighter but
hard and then he had a pretty good tv
career and that's hard to forget he was
on news radio which was yeah yeah i mean
rogan's rogan's establishment yes
exactly
established his credibility in three
different domains and then it's also
extremely difficult to be a good
interviewer you actually have to listen
yeah and he listens
and so
and so rogan's rogan's a very good
example of someone who
as an
individual
stayed closely allied with the truth and
has had well his we have no idea what
his impact is going to be because rogan
has 11 million
listeners per episode now
i see absolutely no reason why he won't
have 20 million listeners per episode in
a year especially if people keep trying
to take him out and it's so funny
especially watching cnn go after him you
know they're all treating the mainstream
media they keep treating joe like he's
the fringe i think are you people well i
know your
these legacy news media
sources are dying all their
really competent people have already
gone off to do other things because they
could
and and they're they're they're living
in like 1975
which is a very weird place to live at
the moment and they look at rogan and
they think
but the cn
cnn guy who was criticizing the other
day said
we have all these departments devoted to
news analysis
yeah yeah rogan is just winging it it's
like you try winging it buddy in front
of 11 million people and see how
successful you would think that's easy
dancing on a tightrope where any word
you say that's false is going to result
in well complete and utter pillaring of
you from multiple news media sources all
over the world every day which is what's
happened to joe nonstop in the last
month despite the fact that he hasn't
said anything stupid so wing it you
think that's so easy it's not so easy
and look what he's done it's like it's
amazing and all he's done
all what do you think's gonna happen
with him with spotify
oh spotify won't won't
remove rogan you don't think so would it
be out of their mind what are the odds
they just dropped from 60 billion
valuation to 36 that's 24 billion you
think the board is sitting there they're
die-hard joe rogan fans or do you think
they're profit margin top line revenue
fans oh i hope that i would rather that
they were the latter the profit margin
types because that's what a corporation
should do and i'd trust them more if
they were doing that but i also think
that
if they have any sense and i know how
this is going to turn out it's it's
turned out in my life like 50 times this
way the heat goes on
the pressure's on you're in the desert
it's unpleasant
you wait it out you waited out you
waited out if you haven't done anything
wrong you wait it out you don't
apologize you don't back down you wait
and things viciously turn in your favor
now waiting it out while you're roasting
that's not pleasant and if the spotify
types have any sense they think yeah
well that's a drop but you know it's
part of the death throes of the legacy
media and once all the dust settles cnn
will have half the viewers they have now
and joe rogan will have twice the
viewers and will be doing just fine and
rogan
as long as he keeps doing what he's
doing he came out on instagram this is
so funny he came out on instagram to
talk about all this a few days ago and i
thought you nailed it joe he come out
and he said it's a paraphrase and i'm
going to do it a bit comedically
he basically said well everyone knows
i'm kind of a lunk head and i have lots
to learn and i probably haven't managed
this like perfectly because i do my own
scheduling and i just talked to people
i'm interested in and so possibly i
could have presented a more balanced
view some of the time and i'll try to do
better in the future and so all the
legacy media said joe rogan apologizes
which is not really the case and then he
talked about how much he liked neil
young and none of this was for show and
none of this was was is that
absolutely and i told the story when he
was at a new young concert i mean
exactly man and so as long as rogan
keeps doing that and i he's been doing
it for five years and he's it's not like
he hasn't faced pressure before
it's clear to me that he's
i just can't see any scenario short of
his assassination that ends up in rogan
not having 20 million viewers
an episode in a year
and so
as long as he's careful like he is
i don't think rogan can be canceled
so even if spotify dumps them it's like
who's dumping who here
rogan he's on spotify it's not
necessarily spotify might be on rogan
it's not so clear and so what what's
going to happen they kick him off well
he'll just have another platform like
tomorrow immediately yeah and he'll have
all the money spotify which was actually
quite a lot of money yeah exactly
did you did you see what pat had to say
about this topic yesterday i don't know
i think rogan is a billion-dollar guy
i think elon needs to sign a 20-year 50
million a year contract with rogan
and start a company like a social media
company choose which route you want to
go direct competitor to youtube to
google to it's not like elon hasn't done
it he didn't create a company that was
revolutionary he went against cars cars
have been around for a while
but what i'm saying is cars and rockets
have been around so it's not like you
wouldn't invented the rocket or invented
a car you don't need to invent something
just go direct against youtube go
directly in spotify go and elon and
rogan could pull it off with the help of
peter thiel it'll work itself out and
they'll recruit the right people they'll
make a few phone calls and the world's
going to come saying hey if you'd like
to have a platform for free thinkers and
where you're not going to be censored
give us a call or you know do this and
it would take off but going back to the
question with you you know i watch you
when you get interviewed and i say this
to myself i'm like okay
here's a clinical psychologist okay what
does he do for a living
uh
you you are in the you you listen to
every
you know prop you know whatever problems
you hear people tell you right
if you really don't want to entertain an
idea and you want to push it away you'll
do it in your own creative way you're
you're you're you're a
you're a heavyweight chain you know
heavyweight type of guy that's gone up
against everybody and you know how to
handle a topic that you don't want to uh
you don't want to talk about or give the
answer to you're a pro you've been
around the block for a while
i just think for you you know to to
uh think about like right now when we're
talking about i think as an individual
we can make more impact than being a pm
or being a president or somebody like
that
uh canada is in shambles right now
because of trudeau's policies
canada is shut down right now because of
true those people not just trudeau you
know there's lots of conservative
premiers in canada well they've done
exactly the same thing let's flip it if
trudeau's philosophies were different
the other guys wouldn't be able to do
what they're doing if trudeau had the
influence at the top it would have been
open can you pull up the mark the john
hopkins article i just want to read this
and get get uh jordan's that article
yeah so so here's cnn msnbc new york
times wapo washington post completely
avoid john hopkins study finding uh
coveted lockdowns ineffective fyi would
you say john hopkins is a conservative
organization like hoover institute no or
heritage johns hopkins is one of the
most reliable medical
scientific research enterprises
universities in the world bar none
that's very important for yeah
it's extremely reliable so it's not like
it's a cnn no no this is like this is
harvard oxford cambridge level johns
hopkins especially in the medical domain
so watches abc cbs nbc also ignored the
anti-lockdown study so go up let me read
this so here we go there has been a
full-on media blockout in the study
online the ineffectiveness of lockdowns
to prevent coveted debts according to
john hopkins university men and analysis
of several studies lockdowns during
first coveted wave in spring of 2020
only reduce covet mortality by 0.2
that is not a lot in us and in europe
while the meta-analysis concludes that
lockdowns have had little to no public
health effect they have imposed enormous
economic and social costs
where they have been adopted the
researcher wrote in consequence
lockdown's policies are ill-founded and
should be rejected as a pandemic policy
instrument if you can go a little higher
i want to read the next two and i'll get
jordan thoughts however the johns
hopkins study received no mention on any
of the five liberal networks this week
according to
uh grabian transcripts cnn msnbc abc cbs
nbc all ignored anti-lockdown's findings
after having spent much of the pandemic
shaming red states with minimal
restrictions and events deemed by
critics as super spreaders it wasn't
just the networks avoiding the study the
new york times the washington post the
associated press reuters usa today axios
politico amongst other outlets also
tuned a black a blind eye to the
findings according to search results
jordan how important is this research
like how important is is this analysis
that we're reading here right now what
does this tell us i should tell you what
a meta-analysis is to begin with
well
imagine there's a group of studies done
on a particular topic and you write a
review and you try to interpret the
findings
that
was called a narrative review you use
your opinion
in some sense to
wade through the data and try to
understand what the compilation of
studies reveals well there were
techniques developed 25 years ago that
are statistical where you can
aggregate the statistical results from
studies statistically so you do a
statistical analysis of all the
statistical analysis and that's a
meta-analysis and hypothetically it's
more objective and there's some truth to
that claim you still have to select
which studies to include but i i don't
believe that that was a detriment in
this particular case and so
solid methodology
and it's basically something
approximating a cost-benefit analysis
and that has it's that's tough too
because it's not that easy to assign
costs and benefits in a quantitative
manner
having said all that it's well it's an
amazing study
not only because of what it reveals
which is a 0.2 decline in overall
mortality but also
in that the
the researchers felt so strongly about
their
findings that they
came right out and said that this was
ineffective policy and that isn't that
common um for researchers who generally
hold off on drawing that sorts of
conclusions they they kind of lay out
the facts out of black and white they're
typically not going to come out as black
and white as what you're saying yes yes
exactly exactly and so
so that's that's really something we
rushed to imitate a totalitarian state
in panic and the consequence of that
according to this study was
there's zero there's nothing positive
about it now i've talked with some
democrats about this study because they
were paying attention to it and their
response is
something like
well
it did help control hospital overrun
and
time will tell whether or not that's
true i think the data
suggesting that covid vaccines decreased
the seriousness of illness when people
contracted covid who were vaccinated i
think that data is
credible
i could be wrong about that because
things are being done in a rush and it's
very difficult to draw appropriate
scientific conclusions in a rush but i
think the bulk of the information
suggests that but i also think that is
not how they were marketed and that was
not the initial intent to merely reduce
severity of the illness it was to reduce
transmission and and so forth and and
then of course this is a cost-benefit
analysis which says yeah there was some
gain on that front conceivably
maybe although all-cause mortality
doesn't seem to have gone down much at
all but the economic
the secondary consequences were
devastating and well we don't even know
what the secondary consequences are yet
you know the collu here's one secondary
consequence
which is revealed in what you just read
the collusion of the press and the
government
like how do you know that's not worse
than the epidemic it could easily be
worse than the epidemic or the idea that
now
we've been
coerced
into
having to share our medical information
with people all through the bureaucratic
hierarchy all the way down to servers
and restaurants so we've trained people
that that's okay to ask and also to
offer
is that worse than the pandemic
well
these are
arguably
all of this involves violation of our
fundamental rights
where's the evidence that that's not
worse well we're going to see it play
out well the collusion between the press
and the government
that's so intense in canada as already
said when the premier of ex-premier of
newfoundland wanted to launch his
constitutional challenge
he couldn't use a mainstream news source
that's a bloody catastrophe much as i
dislike cbc which is a lot by the way
i think that it's an absolute
catastrophe that it's come to that and
that's just one of
you know two consequences of the
lockdown there's the supply chain
problem that's a big one you know i
my publisher penguin told me a week and
a half ago we're talking about putting
out a two-volume
set of my last two books which i would
really like to do they're going to do
that in great britain
i i think that people would
turn to it as a gift for graduations and
so on that would be a nice set for that
they told me they can't get paper
this is penguin random house right and
it's paper
paper isn't that complex given how
complex everything is the fact that
there are paper shortages that's a big
deal i was in a mazda dealership in
canada a couple of be a couple of months
ago now
they had one car
one isn't very many cars
you know and and so we have no idea what
the supply line crunch is going to
produce in terms of economic
seriously and then the next issue is
well how about all the money we've been
printing
you know we've already seen that produce
a massive
bubble expansion in housing prices
that's being driven by other factors
how do we know that's not worse than the
pandemic you know it could easily be i'm
not saying that it is because i don't
know but that's the issue i don't know
and this is partly why
this mad rush to impose top-down
solutions to complex problems this is in
some sense what makes me a conservative
insofar as i am
it's part of the caution i learned as a
social scientist
social scientists i'll give you an
example this is a good example
i worked with this woman named joan
mccord and she was one of america's
great criminologists and uh
a woman who was
involved as a faculty member when very
few women were
she
participated in a study
in in boston
in somerville which is a working-class
community
back in the 30s
they did the first large-scale
intervention to
deflect children from a criminal pathway
so they're looking at
deprived inner-city kids
thinking they have a higher probability
than average to become criminal and and
to suffer all sorts of other negative
consequences as well or to inflict them
and perhaps
you could intervene at an early age and
and stop that or slow it down at least
and so they put together a very
comprehensive set of interventions
parental lessons for the parents
lessons for the kids
health and nutrition interventions
a whole broad spectrum of all the things
you think this was in the united states
in somerville massachusetts famous study
somerville study
um one of the first large-scale
psychological public health
interventions i would say
and targeting a problem that was
troublesome for left-wing people and
right-wing people alike the
right-wingers would think well fewer
criminals that's good and the
left-wingers would think well let's do
some remediation at the root of the
cause so everyone was hoping this worked
and everyone was happy about it the kids
thought it was good the parents thought
it was good the researchers thought it
was good
they also put kids they took the kids
out of the inner city in the summer and
put them out in camp because of nature
and all of that and wouldn't that be a
nice break for them and
then they did the analysis
and the kids in the intervention group
did worse on virtually every measure
worse
like substantially worse
and so they were all shocked and
seriously shocked in a major way in fact
joan mccord was so shocked she spent the
rest of her life going around talking
about what had happened
turns out that it's a really bad idea to
group
anti-social prone kids together
in camps in the summer
because they learn to compete with each
other in terms of the manifestation of
antisocial behavior and they get better
at it it's like criminal camp
and so that
single
consequence of one part of the
intervention was so negative that it
overwhelmed the entire study and
produced negative results so mccord she
was part of a group of very very able
social scientists that i worked with
when i was in montreal
a broad group and it was an
international group
and they beat the drum all the time
never never never never do a large-scale
intervention without building in an
evaluation 25 of your intervention
budget should be evaluation because you
do not know that your stupid
intervention which you think will do
what it you think it will do
that's just a guess
it's a guess and it could go wildly
wrong in 10 ways you don't predict if
you've ever run studies in a lab trying
to predict how people are going to
behave you figure this out real soon
because they don't behave the way what
was the old idea put a lab rat in a cage
under controlled conditions and the
route will do exactly what it damn well
chooses to do
and that's true for rats it's even more
true for people and so these large-scale
interventions
which the pandemic lockdown was
certainly one of those is like and this
is the conservative objection
the law iron law of unintended
consequences
do something large-scale to systems you
don't understand
at all not a bit
you know we have just-in-time supply now
right and you think about how efficient
a economy has to be to rely on
just-in-time supply so it used to be
that if you ran an industry and uh maybe
you're making
uh you're you're a car manufacturer you
have a warehouse full of parts
but the parts are just sitting there and
so that's like money invested that's not
accruing any interest it's a cost and
you have to store it that's cost and so
that's an expense and so maybe you want
to just have your part supplier supply
the parts exactly when you need them and
then maybe the parts supplier has to get
the metal just exactly when they need it
and so on all the way down to the miners
and maybe that's in china then you think
there's 30 steps there and every bloody
thing has to work absolutely perfectly
on time for that to work at all and then
you throw a lock down into that
it's like well you've never run a
business you have no idea how thing how
complicated things are you think
electricity comes out of plug-ins in the
wall you know that's not a complicated
problem you just put the plug in and
there's the electricity and you muck
things up in 50 different directions and
that's what we've done and god only
knows what we've done
and then this issue that the you know
the mainstream press
won't cover this
you think the reason they're not is just
purely embarrassed the fact that this is
gonna
lose lose even more credibility with the
audience that what we've been saying
this entire time we've been wrong we
haven't done real true investment no
i don't think that's it i think no i
don't think that's it if if that was the
reason
i could understand that reason
i think it's part of this
implicit and explicit collusion it's
like this isn't the story and so we're
not going to report it and i think that
economically even that's a foolish
decision because newsweek i've been
reading newsweek recently newsweek has
some journalists they actually have some
real information again which is quite
interesting still a leftover it's still
a liberal magazine yeah but
my experience has been in the last
couple of months i thought oh my god
there's some actual news in newsweek and
so that was that was really cool
but i see all this
not only as collusion which is
absolutely appalling so that's the death
of journalism because journalists are
colluding with politicians it's like
well they're not journalists anymore and
they're also not politicians because if
they were politicians and journalists
they wouldn't be colluding whatever they
are as a consequence of this collusion
is not politicians and journalists it's
some completely new thing now i'm less
worried about it than i might be because
i also see it as part of the inevitable
death spiral of the legacy media
they're dead and why well
they don't have a monopoly over
the dissemination of information at all
youtube for all of its flaws which are
manifold is an unbelievably powerful and
accessible
technology where the cost of entry is
zero it's like no tv station can compete
with that period they're done and then
these print media sources especially
when they're great people barry weiss
might be example leave because they
can't say what they want to they don't
have to lose much of their talent before
all they've got left is hacks and then
everyone can publish to an international
audience instantly online so part of
what we're seeing in the mainstream
media is a technologically fueled death
spiral and i know how large corporations
die so there's this principle pareto
principle which is that
the square root of the number of people
in a given creative enterprise do half
the work and so if you're a news
organization with a thousand people 30
of them do half the work and you think
no and you can think that all you want
but you're just wrong because this is
one of the most well established
findings in social science period
so you got a thousand people and 970 of
them are putting in time and 30 of them
are doing half the work and then
something shifts
those people can't say what they want to
say let's say the 30 the 30. what do
they do well they leave why
because they can
right these are people they're un these
are competent people they're really
smart they're on the edge they're tough
they have immense networks of
connections as soon as the ship rocks
they think ciao you think i need you
it's like you got you got your
priorities wrong you need me they go off
like barry weiss did and start their own
thing and so then you're left with the
970 that was only doing half the work
and then the next 30 competent people
leave and soon all you've got is people
who
run the legacy media and they just and
they say things like well joe rogan
people shouldn't listen to him because
he just wings it it's like how clueless
can you possibly be or or you have
people like at cnn who treat rogan like
he's an outsider despite the fact that
he's pulling in numbers that are at
least five five to eight times their
average viewership
joe is fringe it's like really we'll see
who's fringe here and so and part of
this is purely technological it's like
there's no way these legacy
apparatuses can compete
how can they
printing is printing with universal
distribution is free video with
universal distribution is free how can a
network possibly compete it can't so
spiral death and as they die they lose
their editors they lose their fact
checkers they lose their good
journalists they lose everybody with
courage and then they put out pablo and
they and they're tempted by click bait
because that's what you have to do while
you're dying it's like christ we have to
attract attention somehow so you say
well joe rogan apologized and everybody
clicks on it and they read it and they
think that's a lie and so you've lost
another five percent of your viewership
cnn is probably sitting in their board
meetings saying
god please we need trump to be president
again because when he was president we
were making money
we need somebody like that to be
president they're begging this guy to
come back can you imagine if cnn ends up
like putting him on left and right to
and then you know to berate him but at
the same time they're getting more
eyeballs but going back to it okay so
jordan let's just say you are the pm of
canada let's just play this let's just
say game okay
um
and you watch the decisions justin made
he's your pm you live in that country
how he handled truckers how he handled
vaccine how he handled lockdowns how he
handled everything how would you have
handled some of those things if you were
the pm of canada
well i i'd have to say
that i don't know because
those decisions are extremely
complicated you know and it's it's very
hard to speculate i do have something to
say about that though
that i think is relevant when i watch
mr trudeau
through
through the lenses that i've developed
over the years
i see someone who never
ever says a true word
and so i've met lots of people like that
they're all persona and everything they
do is crafted in a sense
to
obtain what they think is appropriate in
the situation whatever that might be
it's all instrumentality and so when mr
trudeau comes out
and addresses
his audiences
it's all a it's all a game it's all an
act
all of it and so
what i would hope i would have done
differently if i was in that position is
i would have said what i thought
and hope that that
i always think that's the way that
carries the day it doesn't mean you're
right because what the hell do you know
but at least it means you're engaging in
the process that might make you right if
you opened up your eyes and your ears
and listened
right and so
what to do isn't
in a complex situation in some sense
isn't as important as how you do it
right what approach do you take when
when when the chips are down and and
things are tense
the good politicians that i've met
and this is relevant to this
they listen
you know they go out among their people
actually go out and they listen to them
and that way they learn what to do and
that's not opinion polls
opinion polls are
and our
my country and yours to a large degree
is ruled by opinion polls to a degree
you can can't possibly imagine because
the politicians won't take
responsibility for saying what they
think and so then they default to their
handlers and their handlers rely on
opinion polls and opinion polls provide
a bad short-term sample of people's
careless thoughts
and you think well you're following the
public it's no you're not
the entire parliamentary system is set
up to follow the public in an
intelligent way
it's not easy to figure out what people
think
or what they want it isn't even easy for
individuals to figure out what they
themselves think or want it's really
hard and these traditions that we've set
up of representative democracy are ways
of listening to the people that are
measured and thoughtful and long-term
and they're being supplanted by idiot
opinion polls that are run by people who
have instrumental desires they want to
win the next election i know you have to
win the damn next election you know but
pandering to
a mob who's frightened because you
scared them
that doesn't constitute leadership it's
certainly not democracy there's a reason
we don't have direct democracy
there's a reason for that it's like rule
by impulse it's not a good structure
it's not a good strategy
we figured that out a long time ago our
organizations are way too large and
complex for anything like direct
democracy to work we're going to want to
have a we're going to have a vote on
every issue
like obviously not
people just don't have the expertise for
that and it's not like they shouldn't be
consulted they absolutely should be
the voice of the people is the sovereign
master of the political enterprise but
what a leader does is aggregate that
voice
i'll give you an example this is a good
example what a leader does is aggravate
aggregate people aggregate that voice
yes yes yes collects it collects it so i
interviewed jimmy carr the british
comedian he's very very smart car and i
asked him how he did what he did and i
kind of knew this from other comedians
i've talked to he said
the comedy stand-up comedy is the most
dialogical of all the artistic
enterprises i thought what do you mean
by that because he actually you have a
monologue what do you mean it's
dialogical he said well before i go out
on a tour and he's had a couple of
successful world tours so that's pretty
good when you're that funny
that's amazing
he said he'd go out and do 100 shows
rogan does the same thing all the
comedians do the same thing
louis ck does this they all do it they
go to small clubs
and they try out their material so
they're sitting at home trying to be
funny and sometimes they are and
sometimes they're not and then they go
to an audience and they lay out some
jokes and
sometimes people laugh a lot and
sometimes they don't
and so the comedians
who do this repeatedly listen
and then they collect all the things
that people think are funny and so isn't
it so cool is that you don't even have
to be that funny
in some sense to be a comedian
you have to be a little bit funny and
then you really have to listen
and so if you go out to your audience
and you tell them jokes and they tell
you what's funny then you can collect
all the things that everyone thinks is
funny and then you can go on a world
tour and just say things that everyone
thinks are funny exactly it's so cool
it's that that's the pathway
aggregate
exactly exactly so so when the comedians
are doing what what a political leader
who who who is functioning properly does
they're doing exactly the same thing
um i i talked in at length to a canadian
politician preston manning he's on the
right of the of the political spectrum
um and he built a political party from
scratch in canada and became the leader
of the opposition which is no trivial
thing to do in the span of a single
lifetime or even in the fraction of a
career which is what he did and he told
me
um
that what he really liked was going out
to make a speech but that wasn't party
really liked he really liked the
question period
because people would just tell him what
they were concerned about and then he
derived the policies for his party
as a consequence of addressing those
concerns so it was really a bottom-up
enterprise
and so
i would hope that had i been in that
position
i would do what i'm doing when i'm on my
tour which is
watching people and listening to them
and then responding and this happens
first of all when i lecture
which isn't exactly the right word
when i explore ideas in front of people
i'm watching them like a hawk
blinded as i am by the lights you know
but i'm watching to see if people are
following and and modifying what i'm
saying to make sure that everybody's
staying on the track and then i have
thousands of people
i have had thousands of people meet me
in meet and greets after the talks and
then on the street
and i always listen to them
and so
then i can address that those concerns
and then that keeps the
situation dynamic right and
so in in in the uk in the house of
parliament there's this great dome at
the center of the building
and it's the lobby and that's where the
word lobbyist comes from by the way and
the
citizens of the uk have the right to
enter the lobby and petition their
their member of parliament at any time
essentially
and so the lobby is where the voice of
the people meets the voice of their
representatives and it's the center of
the british house of parliament and it's
it's built that way architecturally
which is so brilliant it's
stunningly brilliant the way that that's
laid out and that's exactly right
because the people are somewhat
inarticulate like the truckers
like they're not making an argument in
some sense they're bringing their trucks
to ottawa right now yes exactly and and
and and
people who aren't primarily intellectual
let's say they have to act out their
moral presuppositions
in a more concrete manner but that
doesn't mean they're wrong at all it
doesn't mean that at all
and so then
the job of a leader is to
note that inarticulate expression
and to give it voice
publicly
in in speeches let's say but also
to
have that voice manifest itself in the
body of laws that governs all of us
that's how the system works and so
and the alternative is to
dismiss
that
and that's not a good alternative
or to demonize it which is i want to
read this to you because it goes kind of
based on what you're saying here's a
yahoo news story trudeau flees as
trucker convoys
enters ottawa as thousands of protesters
enter auto canadian prime minister
justin trudeau and his family were moved
from their home to an undisclosed
location somewhere in the city on
saturday afternoon due to security
concerns a freedom convoy of some 2700
truckers entered the canadian capital of
auto saturday to protest through those
through those
securities yes sir security concerns
this is the pm
so kobe 19 policies
uh according to the independent around
100 big rigs blockade blockaded a main
street running past the canadian
parliament building so that's going on
he just tested positive for kovid now
it's coming into u.s they froze the
gofundme account which raised over 10
million dollars and nearly 130 140 000
people that donated and now american
truckers are kind of getting involved
and saying listen we're going to
facebook
kick them off yeah facebook kicked them
737 000 subscribers to that group they
kicked them off yeah you wait till you
see your election this year you're going
to see plenty of that that's for sure
how bad do you think the consequences
are going to be like you you really
think
you know some people i talk to some
people like who are professionals in my
community like what are you talking
about truckers i haven't seen anything
on the news i'm like you haven't seen
anything i haven't seen anything on the
news
you don't know what's going on with
truckers no i read wall street journal
in new york times i know nothing about
what's going on in canadian truckers so
they don't watch obviously fox or maybe
they don't watch podcasts right
but it's not the same thing with the
john hopkins yeah the same exact exactly
it's like how did you know
the point how would i yeah so he said he
says you really think these truckers are
gonna have any kind of an influence on
anything it's truckers you think they're
gonna have any information the way he
said it he said it's like kind of
looking down on them because they can't
express it with intellectuals
the leader of the socialist party in
canada
so hypothetically on the side of the
working class
the the people who are most opposed to
the truckers in canada are the
people who vote ndp the socialists about
20 of the population stably in canada
and now and then we have a socialist
provincial government and they've done
some good you know
i don't want to get into that but like i
said there are people in
on that side of the equation who for
example were fostered in the labor
movement and they had they had things to
say the working class needs to have
their say but the vast majority of
people who vote ndp in canada are
opposed to the truckers it's like
i thought you guys were
on the side of the working class
it's like what's happened well not them
it's like hey man
welcome to the working class those
truckers
well they're all white supremacists and
racists like really in canada are they
now white supremacists really
or nazis in canada
there aren't any of them there was some
dimwit was waving a confederate flag at
the rally and the truckers he was massed
the truckers
stripped him of his mask and chased him
away but all the mainstream press
reported confederate flags at the
trucker rally as if that matters it's
like it's not like there are a lot of
canadians by the way flying the
confederate flag first of all that's not
our country and second most canadians i
would say
don't really know in any deep sense what
the confederate flag stands for i mean
right you know
people aren't that informed and i'm i'm
not being condescending they have other
things to concern
it's comments like what you just said
that validates some people how much of a
role people like george soros plays to
get protesters out there that are actors
and they're not real and they're trying
to
instigate to say dear dude this is how
people are feeling because you know the
biggest mover and shaker emotion is what
anger anger is the way you get people to
say you know what these guys are white
supremacists these guys are this and so
this validates how some people have that
argument it also validates how facebook
does their algorithms they want people
arguing in the comment section because
anger
basically begets more comments and more
yeah basically more eyeballs and more
support
like how many canadians even know what
the hell the confederate flag even means
right
and there's one
like there's 50 000 people who we don't
even know how many people are in ottawa
i've seen wildly different numbers the
idea that there was a hundred trucks
that's just completely insane there's
like 10 times that number
minimum
and so
that's another thing that's so appalling
is you can't actually get accurate
information and then yeah well this
trudeau fleas issue that's
i
don't i don't like that it's not like i
view that with any sense of
satisfaction or
or or delight like i'm not a fan of
trudeau because i don't think he's
capable of saying an honest word and i
truly mean that and i've watched his
speeches over and over watching to see
what's going on with him and all i see
is acting
and
but i'm
why despite that why would i be happy
that
the leader of my country
ran away from a protest citing security
concerns which is a very bad move to
begin with it's like well i have to
leave because you people are so
dangerous it shows weakness well no it's
it's it's worse than that it's it's an
instigation it's an instigation it
because
he said that the reason he had to leave
was because of security concerns which
means you people are dangerous and not
to be trusted and i don't think the
truckers so far
are dangerous and not to be trusted and
i've been watching them handle this
they're they're playing this it's been
very peaceful
for for the number of people who are
involved in the demonstration and that's
despite the potential
effect of instigator types and that's a
real threat
so even with that it's been peaceful and
they're
they've set up food camps to feed the
homeless and they're shoveling the snow
in front of the war monument and now
they have a guard around the terry fox
statue terry fox was a man one-legged
canadian who ran across the country
raising money for cancer and he's a
canadian hero and
his statue was desecrated in the
in the in the language of the mainstream
press they put a fl upside down canadian
flag on it and
put some clothing on him which was
desecration which
okay have it your way in any case the
truckers set up a guard around the
statue so that's not going to happen
again and they seem to be not taking the
bait and so i hope that that continues
and that
this proclivity to instigate which would
be extraordinarily convenient for mr
trudeau and which is an easy out for him
i'm praying that that doesn't happen is
there a reason why you wouldn't show up
to something like this like to support
the truckers or at least lend your voice
no the reason i'm not there is because i
have other commitments right i'm on this
tour and and
people have bought tickets and there's
thousands of them and that's what i'm
doing and
you know i put out videos in support of
them and which i think in some senses
yeah well the video i put out last week
which was a message to the conservative
premiers essentially and the
conservative leader who
lost his position last week because
there was a revolt at the federal level
and so
our main opposition party transformed
leadership last week
in no small part as a consequence of the
trucker convoy i put out this video
calling on these conservative premiers
to drop the damn mandates and so it's i
said i mentioned earlier it's got about
a million and a half views it's called
seize the day
and
that's as if that's as effective or more
effective than me being there
so as far as i can tell and besides it's
the best i can do under the current
circumstances given everything yeah so
um you know you know it's crazy while
this is happening uh
i was listening to charlemagne god you
know charlemagne god i don't know if you
know who he is he breakfast club he's
he's a big-time radio hip-hop guy big
yeah in a hip-hop world
very very well known
at this point
you know i think he's necessary it's not
about a fan i think he's necessary
anybody that's pushing the envelope and
you're fair and you push your own side
salute hats off to you live respect that
guy
he said something the other day on the
podcast which pissed a lot of people off
he says you know what at this point i
miss trump
he said let's get that you know back
here because at least you knew he would
say some and he meant it and you're
like you could say i disagree with this
guy
he's crazy and he's not a fan of trump
no he's now the zero fantastic interview
is not a fan of he asked the question
said who's run this country is the
president uh joe manchin or the
president joe biden who was really but
anyways he said yeah he sent them you
know kamila acted like she got pissed
off but so trump hey maybe we need this
guy back right maybe we need somebody
like that to come and he saw shaq the
other day
can you pull up shaq what he said i
don't know if i want to play the video
to be honest with you if you can find
what he says and maybe do this maybe do
this
press unmute on the video you see that
button on the audio bring it all the way
down but they're going to pick up the
algorithm so go and say shaq vaccine
force just google shack
vaccine force i don't know if you saw
this or not jordan did you see this this
was just yesterday did you see this or
no adam did you read that i have not
okay i know he did say something so so
watch this go shaq rips covert vaccine
mandates you shouldn't be forced to make
something you don't take something
now go all the way down because i want
to read to exactly how he said it
because if they have the whole back and
forth go a little lower go a little
lower go little or
i wish i could show it to you so so the
ladies like well no they're not really
forcing us to take anything says no no
they are no they're not no one's forced
me says what are you talking about if
you don't take it do you have a job she
says no you don't have a job but they're
not forcing me to take you so that's
forcing you
that's forcing you so what is start to
happen is some people charlemagne is
like listen maybe this guy that we hated
on as much as we hated on
maybe he took positions maybe he came
out there and talked to us maybe at
least we had you know
uh uh something to say took a position
on what we had to do rather than hey uh
what are we doing today hey you know
how do we handle the situation here do
you think there's certain people right
now uh because we're in florida so in
florida it's desantis and trump and it's
a very competitive there's a lot of
people that want desantis and there are
a lot of people that don't want the
santas to run for office because they
like him as a governor they're worried
who would replace him but there's still
you know let's go brandon flags outside
of uh you know all these boats that you
see everyone's got some kind of a let's
go brandon flag which i'd like to get
your feedback on how you feel about
brandon if you like this branded guy or
not but uh
trump
your thoughts next election coming in
u.s with everything that's going on
i watched what happened in the united
states with trump and clinton i thought
people liked
they liked the unscripted
impulsive lies of trump better than the
scripted instrumental lies of clinton
what do you mean by that
well
trump trump gave a different speech
generally when he went from audience to
audience he kind of shoots from the hip
kind of
a lot and it isn't obvious to me that
shooting from the hip is really the
right way to lead a country
but
calculating everything beforehand for
maximum impact on your political future
that is not also not a way to run a
country and that's how you get pulled
into
politics by handler by pr by
by
opinion poll by image we have you know
you see politicians we have to protect
our image
it's like really do you you have to
protect your image do you what what's
your image exactly well it's what we
want people to think we are well how
about you be that
instead of being the image of that and
this you see this dialogue taking place
people don't even notice it it's like we
have to protect our image it's like
rogan doesn't protect his image
he doesn't have an image he's actually
there which is why people are listening
to him or or come up with some other
excuse he's a gateway to the alt-right
it's like really this
left-leaning
person with
a high degree of sympathy for socialist
views on the working-class site whose
uh psychedelic experiment or hippie
counter cultural person is a gateway to
the alt-right really that's your story
yeah yeah of all the stupid stories it's
so it's so ridiculous you the only way
you could possibly believe that is if
you knew nothing about it
because that's just not who he is at all
it's preposterous but the only other
explanation is that people are listening
to him because they trust him because
he's trustworthy well god could that
possibly be and all the media forces of
their raid against them aren't
trustworthy it's like well
a lot of that as we already talked about
that's a consequence of rapid
technological transformation much of
that is based on the conversations he
has regarding the backs because prior to
covet or even vaccine mandates
nobody thought that he was center right
nobody oh yeah
he was getting that right because he was
he was
yeah yeah he was hypothetically you know
a founding father of the intellectual
dark web and that was going back five
years ago and everybody review re v you
know viewed everybody who had a
mainstream view let's say viewed all the
people who are in the intellectual dark
web for lack of a better term as
gateway to the alt-right you know brett
weinstein and his and his wife heather
you know
those terrible right-wingers it's so
preposterous and
and and and uh sam harris as well
another you know hyper conservative
person
well it's just not that at all not are
these people actually tuning in and
listening are they just making
assumptions oh no they don't listen no
people who criticize well what happens
often and this is why rogan keeps
growing and popular and it happened with
me to some degree is that
people come because they're curious and
then they do listen and then they think
oh this is nothing like what i've been
told it's in fact the and it and i think
this was particularly true
in my case in relationship to
accusations of say far-right sympathies
it's like
well what about all the lectures i gave
on nazism for like 30 years two of the
biggest educational institutions in the
world
what about those
and then what about this what about the
fact that i had i now have like 300
hours of things i've said online and you
haven't been able to find one
phrase even taken out of context
that was enough to damn me in any
serious sense not one
so now you can take some of the things
i've said maybe about gender differences
in personality and clip them and then
put them in a the most like abysmal
interpretive context possible and warp
that seriously and kind of make an
argument that i'm a misogynist but even
that's incredibly ineffective
first of all because i'm not
the fact that i think there are
differences between men and women and
that i actually appreciate the
differences makes me the opposite of a
misogynist because if you're a
misogynist and you don't like femininity
then you deny that it exists
and it does exist and so and all the
data support that men and women are
broadly more similar than they are
different in terms of their personality
structure there's no doubt about that
but
the differences aren't trivial they have
major influence on occupational choice
for example and the data on that's
absolutely clear from from
from and it's all been generated by
left-leaning psychologists because
the entire psychological research
community the academic community in
general is left leaning so all this data
is showing that there are differences
between men and women at a personality
level has been generated by people who
are antithetical to that idea
politically so
yeah yeah well did you used to get in
arguments with your colleagues meaning i
think 90 plus percent
of professors are left-leaning is that
the number pat i want to say 90 it's 13
to 1 according to washington so more
than 90 so meaning if you're in a room
and there's 13 professors and you're
more
to the right conservative and you're you
know you're in the break room having a
coffee having a having a cake or
whatever are you arguing with your
colleagues how did that work
i didn't argue with my colleagues much
now did they want to argue with you okay
faculty people were irritated at me from
time to time because i worked with the
business school and you know how
reprehensible they are and so that was
annoying because i
my attitude to that was
you think all the sins on the side of
the business school it's like what the
hell is wrong with you that's your
viewpoint you think you're sophisticated
and so but i didn't argue about that
because it just was pointless
i didn't
i argued very seldomly with my
colleagues and i spent most of my i had
lots of colleagues who were friends of
mine although at the university of
toronto
they tended to be people who eventually
went elsewhere and that was more a
matter of happenstance than anything
else
but i had
colleagues who were close friends of
mine at harvard and we got along just
fine and they weren't i wouldn't say
they were also that they were
particularly left-leaning but i would
also say i'm not particularly
right-leaning
you know the fact that i was
branded conservative or right-wing for
that matter really came as quite a shock
to me because temperamentally i'm kind
of halfway between a liberal and
conservative because i'm very
conscientious but i'm also very high in
this trait openness which is a
creativity dimension
and so the openness tilts me more in the
liberal direction and the
conscientiousness tilts me more in a
conservative direction so i kind of
so i suppose
in some ways the easiest political slot
for me is something like libertarian but
in so far as i would put myself in the
political slot but i never thought of
myself as a conservative
so apparently
well i'm conservative in some ways now
um
partly from being a social scientist as
i said i'm a firm believer in the law of
unintended consequences
i also believe the conservative dictate
that the best level of government is the
level
most proximal to the problem
and that's a really good principle even
for for running an organization right is
you want to
devolve power
distribute it as much as possible
facilitate local autonomy and you want
the decision makers to be as close to
the people that the decisions are
affecting as possible
that's actually why i thought brexit was
a good idea
you know it was like two tower of babel
the european union it's like no the
representatives got too far away from
the people very very dangerous and so i
think the uk made a good choice it's
like no we're not especially the uk it's
like center of free speech in the world
all things considered historically
considered
you know
americans and canadians differ on this
to some degree but in canada we kind of
view the american revolution as
englishmen standing up for their rights
as englishmen standing up for them yeah
well
the uk had a
very well-developed tradition of
belief in intrinsic human rights long
before the american revolution i'm not
saying the american revolution was
trivial because it wasn't trivial but
it's a extension and elaboration of a
set of principles that were there
long before the american revolution
occurred
and so
as a canadian uh do you think america is
the greatest country in the world
it's it's
probably yeah
probably
i mean
i was every time i go to the uk i'm
or europe in general for that matter i'm
stunningly impressed
the uk is an amazing place and its
institutions are so
remarkable oxford and cambridge they're
so i mean i was at harvard for a long
time
the depth of history there the the
weight of that tradition the commitment
of people to free speech the uk is an
amazing country
the united states has the advantages of
the uk and then it's much bigger you
have a huge population it's incredibly
diverse
your political institutions also allow
for a diverse range of experiments at
the state level that really seems to be
working out well much better than in
canada for example
the united states
has this amazing theatricality that's
such a potent force it's so obvious when
you come here from canada because
everything in the united states is like
a movie set i was at this
gala
week ago
desantis spoke out at the common sense
society
and it was a european organization set
up to foster free speech
and uh
they had an ex-military guy black guy
sing the national anthem before the
formal dinner started and he just belted
it out you know with this kind of gospel
undertone and this whole culture your
whole culture is saturated by this
unbelievably powerful pop culture that
just
has its tentacles out everywhere in the
world and so he
belted out the national anthem a
cappella in a way you'd never hear a
canadian belt out
canada and then they had another guy
who's also black as it turned out get up
and do the prayer before dinner and you
could just see him channeling that kind
of gospel evangelism that's a big part
of the southern u.s culture and so that
was amazingly theatrical and do you want
to attempt to reenact that no no no no
no i couldn't do it justice and then you
know they showed this video about
freedom that was all theatrical and
and it the americans you americans are
unbelievable you're unbelievably good at
that it's it's it and it shows a culture
that has this immense
belief in its dream
and that manifests itself in
especially in pop culture it just
manifests itself everywhere in pop
culture and and american pop culture
clearly dominates the world
and so and part of it is that
that dream of a better future that's
accessible to all that that is given
voice through all of that pop culture i
mean including the automobile for that
matter because that's an expression of
pop culture and
it's certainly not obvious to me at all
that it wasn't the automobile that
doomed the communists because nothing
says freedom and individual sovereignty
like a 16 year old with a 400 horsepower
mustang you know and i know perfectly
well if the automobile was invented
today the no ordinary person would be
able to have one because they'd be too
dangerous you have to take a 10 year
course and then
you know get them pay a million dollars
a month for insurance and and be encased
in styrofoam and
the car that's a bloody miracle it's
like well why don't we let people go
wherever they want in these unbelievably
dangerous contraptions what's the point
there's almost nothing more dangerous
than driving right and you let kids do
it it's like 16 yeah you can drive why
not it's like well because you run
people you can't drink you can't have a
beer
but you well but but it's so wonderful
and and you have all this autonomy in a
vehicle it just yells out individual
liberty so then you export those to
communist countries it's like you think
you're exporting cars you don't think
there's a political message embedded in
the existence of an automobile so you
haven't thought about it it was crazy
you're saying that because yesterday we
had a guest here mike who said he asked
about a car that i own he says hey you
know is it true about this car and i
said if you want to go drive it and
allegedly yesterday he drove it
allegedly keyboards of cops are
listening to this allegedly he went 170
yes today what's the freeway it's an
sf-90 it's the fastest street car
ferrari it's got a thousand horsepower
he was shocked when you're like yeah
here you go here's the keys he's like
what
have you matched it against the tesla
well zero to 60 tesla will destroy yeah
but to like 210 miles an hour you're
just it's just gonna destroy dude
ferrari's gonna jordan would you like to
drive the car after the show no i mean
by the way you know for one first time
he came to dallas i think i took you you
did i drove you to your hotel and you
were to meet your wife right because you
guys would always travel together very
good conversation what did you have what
car was that that was uh what did i do i
drove you know bentley oh that was a
blue rolls royce convertible that was
the rules
we're at a red light
guy into the car next to us he's like
this charter
he went crazy
what kind of car do you drive right now
mercedes sl550 yeah you guys you can
have any car you want why do you pick
that one that's a pretty legit car by
the way no no it's a nice car well i
bought it five years ago um my
brother-in-law had one which i used to
drive in california i really liked it i
really liked the way it felt it's got
great acceleration it's cool too and so
i
i bought one secondhand one it's like
eight years old this thing or nine years
old but uh it's in great shape and uh i
like it it's two-seater zoom around with
my wife in it and it has a really good
sound system and so we put in uh
whatever we're listening to yeah what
are you bumping when you're driving
what's your music toys cms i like
classic rock okay um i have about an
eight-hour playlist of old jazz and
blues standards uh crooners uh that's
more for the on the romance side of
things i have a really good playlist of
old country and blues music that's about
seven hours long which i really love or
what my wife and i listen to that a lot
the car cranked right up do you have a
particular family i really like i think
okay i was gonna ask you is there
particular names that you listen to more
than anyone neil young does neil young
neil young yeah yeah yeah but but and so
he's in my classic rock collection or he
was because it's on spotify so
i don't know if he's gonna be there much
longer i don't like what john
my son did a real good cover of harvest
moon that's on spotify and so you know
we were neil young fans i liked his
music and i still like his music and and
and artists if they had any sense would
stay out of that political debate
because
they're artists and that's way better
creative barbara streisand came out and
said that yesterday that she's going off
of a spotify school but jon stewart said
it best john stewart's like first of all
we need to keep rogan on there and i
think john was on rogan about a year ago
a year and a half ago when he was on but
he said here was the biggest surprise
when i heard look i listened to neil
young i think his music's great i've
listened to my entire life
but what i didn't think spotify was
going to lose four billion dollars
because of neil young
he was kind of shocked by it but
let me ask a couple stories one do you
follow anything with china are you
somebody that's okay so so sorrows which
we know the name soros here's what soros
said recently and i'm curious to get
your take on
uh this soros is a guy that's worth i
don't know 20 billion dollar guy he's a
guy that is
hated by the right and a lot of people
on the right think he is manipulative
deceptive and he wants to inject his
philosophies politically to this country
but here's what he said he says this is
a bloomberg article soros says china's
real estate crisis omicron threatens xi
rule billionaire philanthropist george
soros and china's xi jinping may fail to
extend his rule of the country later
this year
contrast to what most observers expect
sorosidergy enemies within the party
real estate crisis ineffective accents
and a failing birth rate as factors
working against him internal divisions
in china are so sharp that it has found
expression
in various party publications soros said
she is under attack from those who are
inspired by deng xiaoping's ideas and
want to see a greater role for private
enterprise what do you think is going to
happen with g and china
well my sense of it and i'm definitely
no expert is that
it's not easy for the chinese to
maintain
internal unity
and so they tend to focus on that and
perhaps that's partly why china hasn't
been as expansionist to power as it
might have been maybe that's changed to
some degree in recent years but it's
it's a very large country it has an
incredibly diverse population and so
they have their own problems their own
internal problems which are significant
and and preoccupying and so
i hope that
they stay focused on their internal
problems and that they stay focused on
solving them i mean china
has been
forward-looking enough thank god
to allow
the free-market enterprise
to flourish despite
the proclivity for implementing top-down
radical left state solutions and the
consequence of that has been
first of all now china is a player
in the international scene for better or
worse i think mostly for better i know
that a lot of that was
accomplished on the backs of the
american working class and that's
catastrophic in many ways but the fact
that
there aren't tens of millions of chinese
people starving
that's really good thing for
international security and stability and
that's of no trivial benefit to the
american working class as well and the
fact is that china makes a lot of cheap
stuff that works mostly
and that
people who are more stressed
economically have also benefited to that
to a tremendous degree
so
it seems that
all of that has been good
the twist towards a more totalitarian
mode of governance in the last 10 years
that's obviously extremely worrisome
the fact that china
is a totalitarian state has had a very
negative consequence on us in the west
especially
in the
immediate
uh what would you call it in the
immediate emergence of the of the
pandemic because what we did was we
rushed to imitate a totalitarian state
we thought chinese lockdown we better do
it it's like really
really we better do what the ccp did
well that's what we did and we'll see we
don't know what the consequence of that
is yet we'll see not good
not good
in my estimation and certainly the johns
hopkins studies
study
seems to
it's only a partial study in some sense
they've done the cost-benefit analysis
costs so far we have no idea what the
costs are of having kids in masks for
two years we have no idea what the
consequences are
what that's done especially to
introverted kids who are high negative
emotion because they're going to be
looking for a reason to hide anyways and
who knows what that's done to their
psychological development both as
children and as adolescents we'll find
out over time
but we haven't paid the price for the
pandemic lockdowns even a little bit yet
did we destroy our economy
like these things take a long time
you know they say if you're piling an
oil tanker and
you detect an iceberg in your path you
can see it you've already hit it
because it takes so long for you to turn
that it's too late well in some sense
these huge systems that we're a part of
are like that is that
you can't tell when they're broken
because they take a long time to fall
over and i don't know if our system is
broken but
we're going to find out
and i don't know if the pandemic
lockdowns broke it and maybe they didn't
and hopefully they didn't i mean i was
in new york city
in manhattan a month ago
and it was the first time
i'd really gone out anywhere other than
toronto
and i've been to new york a few years
before and it's a bouncing place
manhattan i love new york it's such an
amazing city you know the fact that
manhattan can even exist is just an
ongoing absolute miracle seven million
people compressed onto that island and
it's it's pretty damn clean and it's
pretty safe and it's really cool and
there's something to do all the time and
you can walk around free and like that
bloody place is a miracle that's for
sure
and it looked pretty good
i thought isn't this something these
people have been locked down for like 18
months and this place isn't on fire
it actually it's pretty clean and most
of the businesses are still open and
isn't that a bloody miracle and which it
most definitely is
and so let's pray and not be too
resentful about all the foolishness
let's pray that
we wake up and we
treat the pandemic like the flu and we
get back to something resembling the
normality of florida and
we put this behind us and we don't get
too upset about january 6th and we don't
get too vengeful about the democrats and
the radical left and we licked someone
half sensible to run the republicans and
we
carefully weave our way through to a
peaceful future we let's pray for that
because the alternative is pretty damn
dismal and i don't think we have to have
the alternative
you know one of it we talked about trump
earlier
here's my dilemma with trump
one of many
he's beating the election with stolen
drum pretty damn hard
and i look at that as an outsider again
because i'm canadian and i think
well you americans you've been split 50
50 for like five decades like right down
the middle and there's always
election
trouble
because no system is a hundred percent
perfect maybe there's like a one percent
two percent margin of crookedness
something like that and
you're probably really not going to get
rid of that maybe you can
maneuver carefully to keep it so that
it's never any more than one or two
percent
but to get rid of that last bit of
malfeasance and deception and corruption
would take such a heavy hand that that
would become worse than the problem
and
that's a real problem when you split 50
50 because small election irregularities
can throw the whole election
okay so
it isn't obvious precisely what can be
done about that but the election was
stolen narrative i think it's weak for a
variety of reasons the first is
it's pretty whiny
like why didn't you win with five
percent margin then
so how do you know this isn't your fault
and you think the republicans aren't
gerrymandering congressional districts
because they are
and so it's not obvious that even if it
is the case that there is
substantive election fraud that it's all
from one side
and so there's that and then
you're sure that's the message you want
to be sending people that they shouldn't
have faith in their most fundamental
institution
you might be right but
but
it's in your interest for that to be
true
and so that's a moral hazard
and then
well what happens when you retake the
house because that's what's going to
happen i think the democrats going to
get stomped in the in the upcoming
election
are those elections somehow valid but
yours wasn't and so
why magically when the republicans get
elected that's honest but when they
don't it's not
and so doesn't that take the wind out of
your story it's like well it was stolen
well you have the house and the senate
how do you account for that so that to
me that that's going to weaken that
narrative trump is capitalizing on anger
he's using the election issue as a means
to an end and he may believe it
but it doesn't matter because it's a
weak story especially when the democrats
lose the house it's a weak story so it's
not gonna it doesn't have any momentum
but then it it's worse than that
because i also think and i've talked to
lots of republicans about this
is that the best story you've got
you've got tradition on your side
you've got the truth as an adventurer on
your side you've got belief in truth on
your side that's been abandoned by the
radical left
you've got belief in science on your
side
you've got responsibility on your side
you've got the fundamental purpose of
higher education on your side
you can't conjure up a better story for
americans than the election was stolen
with all that on your side
that's just not
very impressive
and i have sympathy for
politicians in general
in the united states
congress people have very hard jobs it's
not a job i would like
i don't think it's a pleasant job
they spend a lot of their time
fundraising 25 hours a week on the phone
out of their congressional offices
because otherwise they're not supported
by their party leadership
40 percent of them sleep in their
offices when they go to washington they
don't even have apartments those that do
usually have little bitty apartments
their families aren't there because it's
hard to get families to move to
washington now with dual career families
they don't have much of a social group
they have to
run for their job every two years
this is not a plus they're under attack
all the time and they're micromanaged
and microscheduled
so i'm curious what point are you trying
to make are you trying to make a point
with trump saying the fact that you know
election was stolen because that's
exactly what hillary clinton's position
was for four years that elections were
stolen from her better no better when
she does it oh no i'm not even what i'm
trying to say is i looked at it as a
weak position this is a weak position it
is a weak position she was taken i think
okay but that's the worst of it it's
like really where are you going with
this are you going with the
better story tell a better story if you
want to get reelected is that no no no
no no no
the way to re-election is through a
better story but that's not the reason
to tell it
the reason to tell it is because you
believe it and the for the first time in
my life really i believe this to be the
case conservatives really have something
to sell to young people
and they have the they can sell the
meaning of responsibility
because young people are bereft of
meaning
and most people find meaning in
responsibility
and and when the right talks about
responsibility they kind of do it in
that finger-wagging way that makes
conservatives unpopular among young
people you should be responsible it's
like yeah you should
why
well
because your life is chaotic and
meaningless and you're stuck in this
juvenile surreality
and
it's really painful for you and you're
anxious and aimless and goalless
and then you look at people who have a
life because maybe you could have a life
and you think well what does that life
consist of it's like well you have a
committed intimate relationship there's
one
you have friends that you're honest with
and and playful with so you have a group
of friends you have a job or a career
you know you
you learn how to use your life your time
outside of work in a productive engaging
way you regulate your susceptibility to
the multitude of hedonistic temptations
that are in front of you um
you
pay some attention to your mental and
physical health you make a goal some
goals for the future that are concrete
well there's seven things you can do
they're all responsible things why
because then your life will have some
meaning now you might say well what's
the ultimate meaning it's like get those
things straight first they're not
nothing and maybe you won't be so damn
miserable and bitter and resentful and
angry and aimless and anxious and
frustrated and disappointed and ashamed
if you had
five of those seven things going well
and the conservatives can make that case
no bloody left isn't making that case
it's like for them responsibility is
pretty much equivalent to totalitarian
patriarchal oppression
the conservatives could just take that
say no no our institutions they're
pretty solid
maybe if you don't like what's happening
on the political front you join
a group a church
the elks the rotary
some civic organization get in there and
do your part why not because you should
even though you should but because
well why not meet some people who are
like-minded and have a social group
you think biden can can have the kind of
impact to push people away from the
political party to the opposing side
similar to how goldwater and what they
did back in the days on how
civil rights was handled when
barry goldwater did what he did and next
you know african-americans went from
only 60 percent
of them
voting uh democrat to 92 percent four
years later they went from 60 to 92
percent four years later next election
republicans haven't had a chance on the
african-american vote since 1964. do you
think the current climate is that big of
a climate where the conversion from one
side to the other side to say listen
i don't agree with you guys on censoring
if the guys want to talk leave them
alone the way you handle kovit by
shutting everybody down i don't agree
with that constantly printing money i
don't agree with that do you think it
could be something where it could flip
that that big
i don't know because 20 the next
presidential election in this climate is
a long way away because you know who can
predict the future even a year out
especially given the rate of
technological change that we face now i
mean you don't even know what's
happening today there's so many
technological transformations just today
many of which have world shaping
consequences god only knows where we're
going to be by the time of the next
presidential election but it certainly
does seem to me the case that the
democrats are going to lose big in the
fall
and so you know that's that's what we'll
focus on for the time being we'll see
what happened there we'll see what
happened couple other topics before we
wrap up here so remote work it's a
conversation everybody's having i'm
going to read the vox story uh uh on
remote work and we'll talk a
couple other stories here and we'll wrap
up so vox comes out with this article
remote work isn't the problem
work is okay
executives are nearly three times more
likely than non-executives to say they
want to return to office full-time
according to slack survey
the report found that while nearly 80 of
knowledge workers want flexibility in
where they work
their employer thinks that the
arrangement will lead to a variety of
ills diminishing the company's
collaboration creativity and culture as
people have quit their jobs or stepped
out of workforce
in what's called the great resignation
you've heard that before or the great
reshuffling those left behind have had
to pick up the slack two-thirds of
workers said their workload has
increased significantly since they
started working remotely as if increased
work related work weren't enough
pandemic related obstructions the lack
of child care smaller social support
system has caused many people to have
work outside of paid work so this whole
concept of the great resignation and
what's happening you know some people
are seniors listen you guys got to come
back to work i'm in the financial
industry i can't tell you how many
people are having a hard time getting
their people back like the biggest thing
ceos will tell me is pat we we screwed
up we screwed up taking a position of
it's okay you can work from home because
now
they are only looking for jobs that
allow them to work from home and other
companies are willing to take that
position even though it doesn't work so
we're in a we're cornered right now and
we don't think long term this is an
effective way of running a company what
are your thoughts with the great
resignation
well one of the things i
learned when i was in washington we were
trying to understand
i went there
with a in collaboration with
a group that runs the amer
the presidential prayer breakfast
and so they're
christians
um
self-admittedly let's say who have been
operating in washington since the
eisenhower administration and most of
what they do is bring
people together congressmen and senators
within parties to have some social time
a meal
some chance to talk or across party
lines and they're trying to provide the
kind of hospitality that produces
social relationship
and we talked a lot about this because
one of the things that's happening in
washington that
is
fostering polarization is the breakdown
of the social community
so it's hard to get people to move to
washington often because their spouses
have jobs and so they're localized in
their community
hard to move the kids
and so as i said 40 of congressmen i
believe it is sleep in their offices
and
then
you can do a lot of remote meetings
and
and then you can fly in and fly out
and you think so what oh and then
there's cameras
recording your speeches in the house
that means you're always acting instead
of saying what you think
and so there's this confluence of
technological transformation that's
devastating the under culture of
washington because what used to happen
more
was that
well people would go to each other's
soccer games with their kids you know
their kids soccer games are baseball
games and they get to know each other a
bit and
if i disagree with you
then it's easy for me to think you're
bad because i think
that what i think is right because i
wouldn't take it if i didn't think it
was right if i'm a good faith player and
you might not be bad you might just be
different but i need to get to know you
well what does that mean it means i need
to step out with you
in the actual world
and do something in the actual world
that shows how much we actually have in
common
and a lot of that social like i i had it
lunch i set up five years ago four years
ago
we invited i think eight republican
congressmen and eight democrats
and they were all juniors
and
they didn't know most of the people
within their own party organization much
less people across the aisle and they're
not exactly rewarded for talking across
the aisle either especially when the
leadership has a top-down vision of what
constitutes leadership
and so instead of having them talk about
anything political we just had them talk
about
why are you in washington you know most
of these people
these snake pit dwellers you know in in
the cynical parlance
they had perfectly functional lives
before they went into congress
they gave up a lot to seek political
office you think while they're power
hungry it's like they were doing all
right so it isn't obvious that this was
a step up for them and so all of them
i said take three minutes and just say
why you were here and it was it was the
same speech every single one of them
gave the same speech and it wasn't
nonsense and it was deeply
cinematic in that american sense you
know they talked about their love for
their country and their patriotism and
the fact that they felt that they had to
give back and
every single person now they
personalized that they talked a little
bit about their own story and how they
came to that realization but there's no
way you could tell the democrats from
the republicans not on the basis of that
and i tell you if you were there you
would have walked out thinking
that's a pretty decent group of people
and they're really trying hard that that
i swear that's certainly i was there
with people one person in particular
who's much more tilted to the democrat
side and that was his take on the whole
room
and so
how old were these people
oh anywhere
35 to 45 basically and and so my point
is the problem with the with the
distance work is that
it's predicated on the idea that
everything we do that's important is
done in the abstract
right in the domain of information
exchange explicit information exchange
and that's just not true
so that's a danger because we don't know
what that will do to cooperative
organizations now it might be a good
thing it might be a bad thing i often
meet with my son on zoom when we're
doing business related
when we have a business related matter
because it's actually easier to share
our computer screens
and do what we're doing than it is to
meet in person
but that doesn't mean i don't want to
meet him in person i want to meet him in
person
for sure
so there's that then that's uh beware of
what your technology is doing because
it's doing all sorts of things that you
do not understand at all like it could
be that
the decimation of the underlying
social community in washington
is enough to drive polarization to the
point where the whole system will rock
and crumble we we have no idea because
we don't know why it worked it it worked
you know i've been thinking about online
universities
well that's easy lectures and tests
that's what universities do it's like
no
that might be
maybe that's five percent of what
universities do five percent yeah i
would say so
here
well here's a bunch of things
universities do
they confer an identity upon you
who are you i'm a student
okay
respectable
so for 120 000 let's say it's more than
that sometimes and less than that you
now have an identity for four years that
your culture respects and that means you
have a container within which you can
have intellectual freedom while you're
deciding what you want to do with the
rest of your life instead of torturing
yourself about how useless you are
because you don't have a productive job
yet so that's a big deal god only knows
what that's worth but not nothing
well
how about finding a mate
so there's evidence now coming out i
don't know how reliable it is you know
that it's about
two women for every man in many
academic institutions now
and that
proclivity towards female dominance
seems to be increasing however it
appears that once the men drop to one
third of the population the women stop
going
well
you think why is that well why the hell
do you think it is you go out of your
little town you know you want to find a
new peer group and you're young it's one
of the things you want to do is find a
mate so part of the reason you go to a
good university is because
the sorting has already taken place it's
like well you know this person's got a
high school diploma and they're they're
clued in enough to pursue a college
filtering system yeah so that's a huge
deal and then universities also act as a
filtering system for businesses because
they use the sat as a entrance
requirement so if you hire someone as a
graduate from a high-end university you
knew that they had a high iq because the
s.a.t is an iq test and god only knows
what that's worth and then
you shed your peer group
your old peer group and you establish a
new one maybe when you're a bit wiser
and that's a i mean
one of the major
elements of my college education
was
the transformation of my peer group that
was huge and then there's personal
relationships between you and the
professors if you're lucky enough to
establish them that's a big deal because
then you get to interact with someone
who's
an embodiment of the academic tradition
and see how they act that's different
than listening to what they say in a
lecture and then there's the social
surround the joint meals this is they
make a big deal of this at cambridge and
oxford because the students eat together
in their colleges and god only knows how
important that is
and then
there's the part of being an embodied
actor in that academic tradition and
learning to speak and write and
so that's just a handful of things
universities do and that's not lectures
and tests online
and to reduce it to that might destroy
it completely could easily be and it's
the same with our political institutions
they depend on these
real world
substructures that like like engagement
in civic society we have no idea how
important that is and the fact that
that's starting to deteriorate in
washington could be fatal you know you
know what i would be curious about you
know how in america the the one school
university that was popping 20 years ago
and
everybody said oh yeah i can get my mba
on online it was what phoenix university
phoenix university right
and i recruited a few of their sales
guys and they're legit sales guys
because they they're selling is what
they're selling
um
i saw their sales training was great but
one of the things i'd be curious about
is how much do they get from boosters
like
kids graduate from phoenix university
and they got the degree online like i
wonder oh my gosh i'm so loyal to the
school i got to give these guys 10 grand
you know i want to contribute because
this university changed my life
did it though
like is there you know and so what i'm
saying like because for saying there's
no culture i don't think again how do
you do that like you know you want me to
go to church on sundays on a zoom yeah
okay great fine yeah i'll do it i'll
listen to service i mean all every
church does it nowadays and they'll say
our service today was viewed by 73
countries because youtube said 73 oh
we're 73 countries right but am i sold
you know am i really emotional i don't
know i i i don't
your point about the five percent
lecture and you know well you also don't
know what people were doing when they
went to church and people were cynical
about that the people who fell out of
the church they say well you know
they're one hour a week christians it's
like
well better an hour of contemplation of
higher order moral virtue than zero
so zero's not much and you think well
the church didn't do that good a job
it's like okay do do better
see if you can do better
and so but but then also well what are
you doing when you go to church well
you're singing
that's not nothing with other people
that's not nothing
you're
trying to orient yourself ethically
with your community
you're sacrificing a part of your
weekend to indicate your
willingness to do so
like you're you're in a drama right
you're acting out something it's not
it's not merely fictional it's like we
get up in the morning and
you saw this in the simpsons all the
time with marge simpson trying to get
her family to go to church which they
did it's like get up put on a suit dress
up go out there with members of your
community and show your allegiance to
something higher
and the atheists are cynical about that
sort of thing you know because they
reduce god to a set of propositions but
they don't have any real appreciation
for the embodiment
it's like i was in these beautiful
chapels in cambridge and oxford my god
they're so beautiful it's just beyond
comprehension they're so stunningly
magnificent
and the boys choirs were singing when
they they have excellent boys choirs
they're like world class and then they
read these ancient words and those
things ring true and there was a bunch
of ideological nonsense at one of the
chapels i went to and that was
off-putting but
you have to be there and doing that for
that to work right it's it's not
replaceable in any real sense by a
virtual experience because it's not just
information content
or it's not abstract information content
it's the acting out of something that's
what happens
when you join a civic club
you know it's it's a mark of it's a mark
of willingness to participate it's a
mark of faith in the system and you
think well i'm cynical about the damn
system it's like good for you you're not
naive you know thumbs up for you but
sin you're gonna top out in your wisdom
at cynicism
that's pretty dismal man you can do
better than that like cynicism that's
that's beginner's place how often do you
go to church
that's a good question um i don't attend
church
um and so you might think that makes me
a hypocrite and possibly it does
i would say i participate avidly in
civic enterprises however
you know and for me
this
the
lectures that's a church for me
you know i'm trying to make things
better
and i think i'm participating with
people my audience members
my viewers and listeners
they're committed to making things
better and they're committed to i hope
at least in some sense they're committed
to the truth
and so
it's always been awkward for me to go to
church because for a variety of reasons
and some of that might just be the
unwillingness to do it but i find myself
uncomfortable in them often because
i always got the impression that the
people who were reading the words didn't
believe them
the trudeau factor yes
yeah and so
that's not necessarily any reason to be
cynical but then again i'm not cynical
about religious matters so quite
contrary
so i had a guy i had a guy marvin delvay
you know who marvin delby of course
so you're his hero okay
you he brought you up at the event in
front of 6 000 people okay he says
patrick i'm begging you if you can ask
this question he's a catholic
and he's a very very well-read catholic
okay
and he when i he's from honduras he's
done well for himself in business
and when i read this question for you
you're going to realize how technical of
a question he's asking you okay
uh and and i'm curious to know what take
you know what your takes gonna be on
this it has to do with
a comment you made about the catholic
church right let me read this to you see
if i have it here we go okay it's
long-winded so just brace for impact so
in his video
who dares to say he believes in god he
criticized the catholic church very
harshly
is not
uh the first that he had done and he
basically compared the catholic church
to the protestant approach to salvation
number one number two he then had the
opportunity to interview bishop baron as
part of his podcast name christianity
and the modern world and most of us
expect him to ask some really tough
questions about the issue he criticized
but he never had never happened he
almost looked overwhelmed by the moment
in the conversation he almost looked
like a man that wanted to confess okay
first question he's got three of them
here for you number one
why did he avoid the tough questions
bishop baron was the best person the
most qualified person to clear what i
believe is a mistaken perspective about
the catholic church number two
he was also just coming back from a
difficult health situation he
experienced in 2019 did that influence
his approach to the conversation you
called me
the day of my birthday september 20th i
called him let me know that he was
really not doing well you when you you
know you
we knew kind of what you were going
through i was very emotional and was
praying for him ever since you have to
realize this guy's a true believer of
you number three my final question is
about the catholic church to which
catholic church is he referring to the
latin american catholic church that was
heavenly influenced by liberty
liberation theology for the last 60 plus
years
by the way very poor catholic church b
the very wealthy north american catholic
church see the european catholic church
that almost like and uh and angelican
church feels like a social club d
the grown missionary african catholic
church also very poor and persecuted
church the russian catholic church
suffering persecution by the russian
orthodox church the asian catholic
church persecuted by the chinese
government or the persecuted almost
decimated catholic church at the east
his he talking is he talking about the
pre-vatican the second or the
post-vatican the second church is he
familiar with the current conflict that
emerged from the vatican the second
he made a blanket uh statement about the
catholic church which church is he
talking about does he know the
difference between them
between the missed opportunity with
bishop baron and
not being specific enough about his
position with the catholic church he
left a lot of unanswered questions where
do you stand with that
well one of the things i
learned from reading carl jung i mean
this isn't a statement he made
explicitly but
but it's
it emerges as a consequence of
reviewing a fair bit of his thought
his proposition in some sense was that
catholicism was as sane as human beings
could get
and it's a very interesting rejoinder to
the atheist types because they think we
could be rationalist materialists
but i don't think we can be because
that isn't what we're like
or we're all going to become rational in
in this scientific sense
it
there aren't that many scientists and
even among scientists there aren't that
many scientists it's actually really
hard to be a scientist you it takes a
lot of training it's a very specific way
of thinking and
it isn't how obvious how broadly
accessible that's ever going to be and i
say that as an admirer of the scientific
enterprise
catholicism is a great drama it's a
inclusive encompassing
ritual in drama as well as a system of
beliefs and you know more power to it as
far as i'm concerned on that regard i
don't remember what my fundamental
criticism was unfortunately i there's
many podcasts that i've done because i
was so ill and sometimes well doing them
that i don't i don't remember them at
all
i meet people that i interviewed for two
hours and i don't remember meeting them
it's very distressing but that's life
um
i would say and i think the idea that a
critique should be differentiated that's
that's a very good idea and and fair
enough and i certainly don't
feel like engaging in a blanket
condemnation of the catholic church
i've i've been grappling
and trying to do this with bishop baron
too
part of the reason baron wanted to talk
to me is because
the
people who are actively engaged in the
religious enterprise professionally and
this is
orthodox jews muslims
orthodox christians roman catholics
protestants
protestants less so but some
they're
interested in
the popularity of my
lecture series on genesis
because
i did that lecture series in 2017. it
was really the first public lecture
series i gave we rented a theater in
toronto privately
and
booked it for 15 weeks and i offered
these lectures and
all the tickets sold out and most of the
people who came were young men and
that's weird
because you imagined going to a bank
with this business plan
so i'm going to run a thing i want you
to loan me some money i'm going to run a
theater i'm a professor i'm going to
rent a theater
and i'm going to lecture the first
lecture i'm going to give will be two
hours on the first sentence of genesis
and my target market is young men
it's like they're not going to lend me
any money that's that's a no starter but
the the
lecture's sold out and they've been
watched i don't know 40 million times or
something on youtube
and so the
the
civil apparatus of many religious
organizations are interested in this
because i obviously tapped into
something that they're not tapping into
and
my criticism
if i remember was a criticism
aimed at addressing the fact that that's
not being tapped into one of the things
i talked to bishop baron about and i may
not be addressing your friend's concern
because i don't know what specific
criticism he was
he was uh
he was concerned about
i suggested to baron that the reason the
churches the church the catholic church
is not doing as well as it might there's
many reasons is that they actually in
the attempt to popularize the faith
especially in the 60s they ended up not
asking enough of people
so we shouldn't ask so much like no
wrong decision meaning
expect
make it more excessive got it like got
it yeah
okay one thing i learned from reading
kierkegaard you know kierkegaard said at
one point in real comical piece of
writing that once everything has become
too easy that there'll be a massive
outcry for
voluntary difficulty
and i thought that's smart well he was
smart he was kierkegaard after all and
the church can offer that
that is what it has to offer like that's
the straight narrow path this is very
very very very very difficult but it's
alternative to hell
so there is that and i think that's
there's true and there's meta true and
that's
meta true that's that's powerful because
you know
churches sit behind closed doors and the
board will say whoever the board may be
at a non-denominational church hey
pastor this last time you talked about
you know pick whatever it is
transgenderism a little bit too much
we we're losing our you know attendees
you talked about this don't spend too
much time talking about gay marriage out
of the bible because we have to be a
little bit more diplomatic
you know
don't let's not raise the standard too
much where people are doing too many
bible studies or too many you know
whatever you know events at the house
you're saying no double down and raise
the standards and keep them high expect
more from people that's what you're
saying
yeah absolutely and
and it isn't and not in a finger-wagging
sense it's more i've been thinking i've
been talking to a lot of
islamic thinkers and i have a lot of
people who
a lot of muslim people have watched my
biblical lectures like a lot
and so i have a following strangely
enough among the muslim community and
among orthodox jews and broadly among
religious communities
and
you know the christians are often on me
to come out and just profess my faith in
jesus christ as our universal savior
um whenever i'm
let's say questioned in that manner it's
always a trap
it's like join my club it's like yeah
you just stay in your own club
and i've got lots of people to talk to
you know
but
a huge part of
you know the the muslims say it's pretty
funny
peterson doesn't realize but he's
actually a muslim and
and i had an
orthodox jewish fellow in new york
make a comment about his friends
watching my videos and
seeing them in accordance with the
deepest elements of their teachings and
it's a lovely thing to see it's very
surprising to me it's quite staggering
but
you know what i'm doing is predicated on
the idea that
there's way more to people than they let
out
and a lot of that's to be found in their
darkness
and i'm
making that case
i suppose the people who've been most
attracted by that case have been young
men and i think that that's because
they're so actively discouraged in the
expression of their possibility by our
culture
actively discouraged because
they're regarded as you know oppressive
patriarchs in training or some bloody
thing like that and so caustic and so
horrible i guess the question the
question i was more asking is you know
the ideas if we lower the standards
attendance will go up
we've been losing attendance because
standards have been very high let's
lower a little bit let's be more
welcoming you know and more political
and more relevant it's like
religion isn't politics
religion is that is the structure that
contains politics it's far deeper it's
like
politics literature religion that's sort
of the structure
so
politics literature yeah politics is
embedded well you americans i said
you're all theatrical here well it's
because your whole polity is is
encapsulated in narrative everyone knows
that that's the american dream it's like
what's the american dream well it's hard
to put your finger on it and you guys
are exploring that all the time not
least in your popular culture
it's constant exploration of what
constitutes the american dream that's
the container for the political
structure and it's the dream that unites
you the political structure does as well
but it can't unite you if the dream
doesn't unite you and underneath so the
dream is that's in the domain of
literature essentially in storytelling
and dream and underneath that the
deepest strata of the literary endeavor
is the religious endeavor
the bible is a story
is it true well it depends what you mean
by true and people say well that's
weasely it's like no it's not
if you ask a profound question like that
is the bible true
you can't assume true and then cram the
bible into that you have to make both
sides of the equation open to question
what do you mean by true
well you're not answering the question
no i'm just not answering it the way you
want me to
i'm not this is why people like richard
dawkins always kick the hell out of
religious people when they're debating
them it's because dawkins comes armed
with a conception of the truth and it's
not trivial it's like the scientific
conception of the truth this is a big
club
and before he even begins
this the whole structure of the debate
is predicated on
the fundamental acceptance that that
definition of true is
valid and complete and so the religious
people just lose because they're up
against the might of science it's like
how are they not going to lose that so
what do you mean by god is not great is
that
yeah i've read it and by the way he
he is uh very very influential how he
influenced the world by the way i want
to keep you on time
yeah very i had a conversation with him
at oxford we're going to release that
couple of weeks how long ago was that
a month ago oh it's very cool yeah
that's fascinating but yeah i would have
liked to talk to him for like 35 hours i
bet i can only imagine that especially
so how much more time do we no
i got to wrap up because
it's
anyways let me show you this neighbor of
mine asked me this question he's
canadian he says can you ask jordan
peterson this go to the picture with uh
uh uh trudeau
what what can you say about this this is
your world i don't know if this is this
even talked about over there with the
whole story of justin trudeau's
you know related to castro because years
ago like is this is this a
show the other picture where this other
guy posted it so apparently this is uh
uh go to the picture of a fidel the wife
and the father so this is a picture
of them three that's his mother that's
him that's the father but then you put
justin right next to castro can you go
back to the other picture on twitter
yeah that one right there
it looks really similar yeah is there
any is this even a conversation in
canada has anybody been telling because
this is written about many many
different places to the point where they
tweeted about it and said no
castro is not justin trudeau's fault
it's a it's a nasty it's a nasty bit of
innuendo and
i think it's it's
it's it's resentment fueled
fundamentally like in some sense it's a
satirical joke you know and fair enough
but it's
it's not helpful
look
one of the things that happens if you're
a political leader is you you're exposed
to criticism of all sorts and and part
of that's to stop
your power from degenerating to
something approximating a tyranny so you
kind of have to put up with it
this i would say is
i i wouldn't
propagate the idea
okay um
first of all
just
it's speculation clearly
it's mean-spirited speculation
uh on the part
in relationship to the behavior of
trudeau's mother
even if it was true
then well what's your point
he's born a communist that's your point
that's a stupid point
you know or what he knows that castro is
his father and so now he's tilting hard
towards the left to please him well
that's
that's not helpful and clueless
now
the trudeaus in some sense set
themselves up for something like this
because
trudeau
played the senior played ftse with
castro in a way that was rather unique
in the western world and i think that
was
ill
that was not a good decision
he was less
stringent in drawing a line between
the left and the radical communist left
that he might have been and so those
chickens have come home to roost in some
sense in terms of this assault on his
son
and justin himself
doesn't do a very good job of drawing a
distinction between his views and the
views of the radical left
and so all of that's mangled around in
this satirical attack but
i don't think it's the most effective
it's it's got an element of real
gossipy innuendo and mean-spiritedness
about it that
i think
overwhelms whatever humorous
satire it might also contain
so i mean they did this with obama's uh
uh you know when trump came out and said
five million dollars prove to me your
birth certificate you're born these
types of stories tend to do well and
they tend to go viral but you know this
is just when you look at this it it's
it's uh
it looks a little too uh too real to you
know that's why people are given the
credibility anyways we are at the end of
the podcast jordan i appreciate you
coming out couple things gank if you are
in florida he's performing he's speaking
tonight if you can't even get the
tickets
at miami florida fillmore
today the third no it was yesterday i'm
sorry seven oh i'm sorry seventh you're
going to be in houston yeah it's where
you'll be at the
uh bayou music center eight you'll be in
midland texas ninth year in irving 10th
in san antonio 15th in new york
16th in new york 17 in providence 21st
norfolk virginia then dc on the 22nd
philadelphia 23rd boston 24 we're going
to put the link below if you haven't had
a chance to go spend some time with this
man i highly recommend you take your
family wife kids
and have them hear from him because he's
going to get everybody thinking and at
least a great conversation
and uh i have a feeling this will not be
the last time we'll have you on again
jordan thank you so much for coming on
see you guys again yes and what we're
doing is every time we get a guest
somebody signs one of these lock boxes
you pick one sign it up there so we know
jordan peterson was in the house folks
uh this has been a week of us doing
podcasts four times i think we got some
lineup next week's only even one time
because i'm all over the country but
it's been great uh having jordan on
today hope you enjoyed it as much as we
did give it a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel tyler you look like you're
taylor you look like you want to say
something let's say we got rolo tommaso
uh tomasi tuesday yeah and then maybe a
few other things in the workplace we do
have a lot of surprises coming up we
just can't reveal it right now but
anyways take care everybody bye bye bye
bye
you